I'M GONNA CALL OF
THE SENATE BUDGET IN FISCAL
REVIEW SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER ONE
ON EDUCATION TO ORDER. AND TO
LET ME GO THROUGH OUR PROCESS.
IN RESPONSE TO THE COVERED
NINETEEN EMERGENCY IN TO PROTECT
THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS AND
EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS THE
SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS.
WE'RE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARING TODAY. IN THE CAPITAL.
SENATOR MAN WILL BE ABSENT TODAY
WE EXPECT CENTER OR CHOI BOGUE
IN A MOMENT OF THOSE PROVIDING
TESTIMONY BEFORE THE COMMITTEE
TODAY ARE PARTICIPATING REMOTELY
FOR REMOTE PARTICIPANTS PLEASE
MUTE YOUR PHONES OR COMPUTERS
THIS WILL GREATLY AID IN
ELIMINATING ANY ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK. I ASKED EVERY TIME YOU
WISH TO BE RECOGNIZED THAT YOU
USE THE OF RAISE YOUR HAND
FUTURE IN THE PROGRAM. AND EACH
TIME YOU ARE RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK
A POP UP WINDOW WILL APPEAR
ASKING IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO ON
MUTE. WE SELECT ON MUTE BEFORE
YOU BEGIN SPEAKING R. I. T.
PERSONNEL WILL PUT YOU BACK ON
MUTE WHEN YOU ARE DONE. ONCE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK PLEASE MAKE
SURE THAT YOU CAN BE SEEN ON THE
SCREEN STATE YOUR NAME AND THEN
YOU'RE READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. TO ALLOW PUBLIC
ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC. IN THE HEARING
ROOM TO THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW.
AND WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
TODAY. FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT. THE PARTICIPANT TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE. OUR
IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE AND I EXPECT IT'S GOING
TO SHOW UP ON THE SCREEN
MOMENTARILY. R. I WILL ANNOUNCE
IT NOW. TODAY'S PARTICIPANT
NUMBER IS. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN TWO
TWO SIX EIGHT ONE SIX THREE.
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN TWO TWO SIX
ONE SIX THREE AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS SEVEN THREE SIX TWO
EIGHT THREE THREE. SEVEN THREE
SIX TWO EIGHT THREE THREE FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON. HOW
THE TELECONFERENCES TO MARKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATOR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE I DON'T THINK
IT APPEARED ON THE SCREEN BUT
WHO WILL APPEAR ON THE SCREEN
WHEN WE GO TO PUBLIC COMMENT BUT
IT WILL BE THE NUMBERS THAT I
JUST READ TO YOU. WHEN WE MOVED
TO PUBLIC COMMENT YOU WILL BE
PROMPTED BY MODERATOR TO DIAL
ONE THEN ZERO. PRESS THIS ONLY
ONE TIME AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR
AN OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A LONG
NUMBER. THIS CAN BE A SHORT WAIT
ONCE YOU RECEIVE YOUR LONG
NUMBER YOU OR WAIT IN THE QUEUE
FOR MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR LINE
NUMBER. AT THAT TIME YOU WILL BE
ON MUTED AND YOU ARE NOW READY
TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. PLEASE
NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU MUST MUTE
THE DEVICE YOU WERE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY. AND ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHOSE DISRUPTIVE MAY BE REMOVED
FROM THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE
OR HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED
. BUT TODAY IS THE- SEVENTH OF
NINETY NINE HEARINGS ACROSS
FEBRUARY AND MARCH FOR SUB
COMMITTEE NUMBER ONE. IN TODAY'S
HEARING WILL HAVE THIRTEEN
DISCUSSION ITEMS FROM FOR THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
HASTINGS COLLEGE OF THE LAW
CALIFORNIA STATE LIBRARY
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY.
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES IN
THE CALIFORNIA STUDENT AID
COMMISSION. ARE WE REALLY TODAY
COVERING THE REMAINING
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSALS AS
WELL AS OVERSIGHT ON
IMPLEMENTATION OF BUDGET ACT
AGREEMENTS. SO WITH NO FURTHER
ADO- AND I HAVE BEEN AND JOINED
IN THE HEARING ROOM BY SENATOR A
TROUBLED. BY WITH NO FURTHER ADO
WILL MOVE TO ISSUE NUMBER ONE
WHICH IS HASTINGS COLLEGE OF THE
LAW. A BASE INCREASE IN GENERAL
UPDATES- WE HAVE A PANEL THAT
WILL INCLUDE JACK'S WALLED THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE JASON
CONSTANT TOURISTS OF THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
DAVID BAGMAN CHANCELLOR AND DEAN
OF THE HASTINGS COLLEGE OF LAW
AND DAVID STEWARD THE CHIEF
FINANCIAL OFFICER FOR THE
HASTINGS COLLEGE OF LAW. I WILL
TAKE THE PANEL. IN THAT ORDER
AND THEN WE WILL BE OF. OUR
ASKING ANY QUESTIONS AFTER ALL
FOUR HAVE SPOKE SO WE'LL BEGIN
WITH MISTER SWELLED FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WELCOME TO
THE COMMITTEE. GOOD MORNING
SENATORS JACK'S WELL ON FINANCE-
THANKS FOR GIVING ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DISCUSS- UC
HASTINGS COLLEGE OF LAW'S BUDGET
WITH YOU THIS MORNING. YOU SEE
SINGS IS AFFILIATED WITH THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA SYSTEM.
WHAT IS GOVERNED BY ITS OWN
BOARD OF DIRECTORS LOCATED IN
SAN FRANCISCO IT PRIMARILY
SERVES STUDENTS SEEKING INTEREST
OFFERED FREE BUT ALSO AS A
MASTER OF LOS PROGRAM IN A
MASTER'S OF STUDIES BOND PROGRAM
- IN TWENTY TWO ONE. EASIEST IN
GENERAL NINE HUNDRED AND FORTY
FOUR FULL TIME EQUIVALENT
STUDENTS. AND ANNUAL TUITION FOR
ITS JURIS DOCTOR PROGRAM THIS
YEAR'S FORTY SIX THOUSAND THIRTY
THREE DOLLARS. THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROVIDES TWO MILLION
DOLLAR ONGOING GENERAL FUND
AUGMENTATIONS SUPPORT OPERATIONS
BRING HASTINGS TOTAL GENERAL
FUND APPROPRIATION IN THE BUDGET
YEAR TO TWENTY ONE POINT NINE
MILLION DOLLARS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WE'LL MOVE ON TO
THE OHIO. MORNING COMMITTEE
JASON CONCENTRA CELIYO. A FEW
WEEKS AGO YOU HEARD US RAISE A
NUMBER OF CONCERNS WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED
AUGMENTATIONS FOR THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA. WE DON'T SHARE
THOSE SAME CONCERNS- FOR THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED AUGMENTATION
FOR HASTINGS THERE'S A FEW
REASONS FOR THAT. MOST
FUNDAMENTALLY- UNLIKE UC
HASTINGS HAS PROVIDED THE
LEGISLATURE WITH AN EXPENDITURE
PLAN ASSOCIATED WITH THE
AUGMENTATION. YOU CAN SEE THAT
EXPENDITURE PLAN ON PAGE FIVE OF
YOUR AGENDA AND NOT AYE TABLE.
YOU'LL SEE THE TABLE TOTALS A
LITTLE UNDER FOUR AND A HALF
MILLION THAT'S LARGER THAN THE
PROPOSED TO MOLD MILLION DOLLAR
GENERAL FUND AUGMENTATION.
THAT'S BECAUSE IN ADDITION TO
RECEIVING A GENERAL FUND
AUGMENTATION THE SCHOOL ALSO
PLANS TO INCREASE- STUDENT
TUITION LEVELS GENERATING
ADDITIONAL REVENUE FOR MORE
EXPENDITURES. I NEED YOU SHOULD
BE GETTING THIS- BUDGET YOUR
PLAN HE SINGS ALSO PROVIDES A
LEGISLATURE WITH AN INITIAL
MULTI YEAR PLAN GIVING SOME
SENSE AS TO WHERE IT'S HEADING
OVER THE NEXT SEVERAL YEARS.
OTHERS LONG TERM PLANIS NOT A
MULTI YEAR CONTACT- AND SO THE
LEGISLATURE ISN'T BEING ASKED TO
COMMIT TO ANY SORT OF MULTI YEAR
AGREEMENT UNDER THIS PROPOSAL.
I'M GIVEN THESE FACTORS WE THINK
THIS PROPOSAL IS A REASONABLE
STARTING POINT- THAT'S SAID THIS
IS A STARTING POINT SO WE DO
RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE REVIEW
THE BUDGET PLAN BEFORE IT.
ENSURE THAT IT ALIGNS WITH
LEGISLATIVE PROBLEM. ONE FINAL
POINT I WANT TO RAISE- THE
SCHOOL IS CURRENTLY UNDERGOING
INITIATIVE TO CHANGE ITS NAME.
AND THE SCHOOL INDICATED TO OUR
OFFICE THAT THAT NAME CHANGE
COULD COME WITH SOME ADDITIONAL
ONE TIME COSTS ARE FOR EXAMPLE
COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH CHANGING
OUR BUILDING SCIENCE THOSE COSTS
ARE NOT INCLUDED IN THE SCHOOLS
BUDGET YOUR PLAN SO THAT'S
SOMETHING THE LEGISLATURE I WANT
TO KEEP AN EYE OUT FOR. EITHER A
REVISION OR IN THE FUTURE
BUDGET. THANK YOU. THANK YOU-
MISTER CHANCELLOR- THANK YOU AND
GOOD MORNING SANDERS- IT'S GREAT
TO BE WITH YOU THIS MORNING- THE
CAMPUS IS A VERY STRONG AND
GROWING IN A SUBSTANTIAL WAY IS-
REGARDING AN EXTRAORDINARY CLASS
THIS PAST FALL I WAS STRONG
METRICS AND DIVERSE BACKGROUNDS
ARE ENTERING CLASS WITH AROUND
FOUR HUNDRED I WOULD HAVE
IDENTIFYING AS STUDENTS OF
COLOR- AND 56% ARE WOMEN. ARMAR
PERFORMANCE- CONTINUES TO BE
VERY STRONG ARE THE CLASS OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE HAD AN 84%
PASS RATE OF THE OVERALL FIRST
TIME PASS RATE OF 83% ARE WE
HAVE BEEN VERY ACTIVE OVER THE
LAST SEVERAL YEARS EVEN DURING
THE PANDEMIC I AM CREATING
DIVERSE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
STUDENTS- INCLUDING A PARTICULAR
CREATING NEW CENTERS- WE HAVE
NEW CENTERS ON RACIAL AND
ECONOMIC JUSTICE. I'M BUSINESS
LONG- ON INDIGENOUS WA AND NON
TAX LAW IN THOSE JOIN OUR A LONG
STANDING CENTERS IN AREAS LIKE A
WORK WIFE LAW- CENTER PRETENDER
REFUGEE STUDIES AND THE UCSF UC
HASTINGS CONSORTIUM ARE WE ARE
ALSO VERY ACTIVE- AS THE
SENATORS NOW AND DEVELOPING
PARTNERSHIPS AND CORPORATIONS-
WITH OUR SISTER UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA AND CSU CAMPUS IS. A
WE HAVE A LONGSTANDING AND
FORMAL PARTNERSHIP WITH YOU SEE
ESTARÁ I UC DAVIS IS GRADUATE
SCHOOL OF MANAGEMENT RUNS A
MASTERS OF SCIENCE PROGRAM IN
BUSINESS ANALYTICS ON. OUR
CAMPUS HERE IN SAN FRANCISCO.
AND MORE RECENTLY WE ARE AND
HAVE BEEN DEVELOPING CROSS
PROGRAMMING- WE CAL. AND OBISPO
- AND WEARING OR WE COME. WITH
YOUR CAL SAN. I WAS NOT A LOS
BUT IS INTERESTED AND WANTS ALSO
MEASURE THAT. I THIS THE HAS
AWAY- WE HAVE BEEN ON OUR
CALIFORNIA'S PROGRAM OTHER
CALIFORNIA'S PROGRAM OF COURSE.
AWARDS SCHOLARSHIPS YOU
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS WHO ARE
GRADUATES OF THE H. B. C. USE.
IT'S BEEN AN EXTRAORDINARILY
SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM- IT IS ALSO-
ON A NUMBER OF OTHER INITIATIVES
I INCLUDING THIS PAST YEAR WE
SIGNED A REQUEST PREPAYMENT WITH
SPELMAN COLLEGE IN ATLANTA. ARE
SO THAT THEY SPEND THEIR FIRST
THREE YEARS AT SPELMAN I THREE
YEARS OKAY THINGS AND THEY GET
OUT THE DEGREE. FROM SPELMAN THE
DEGREE FROM PACE OF. OUR
BUILDING OF THE ACT AND THE BILL
WOULD IN A HEART CAMPUS DISCO
CONTINUES AT EIGHTH AVENUE
BUILDING THAT WE'RE BUILDING AT
ONE NINETY EIGHT MCALLISTER AT
THE CORNER MCALLISTER AND HIDE-
IS SLATED TO BE. COMPLETED IN
JUNE TWENTY TWENTY THREE- IT
WILL HAVE SIX HUNDRED FIFTY FIVE
UNITS OF HOUSING- AND I WE ARE
SHARING THAT WITH THE UNIVERSE
CALIFORNIA SAN FRANCISCO. I
ENJOY A PART OF OUR GENERAL
PLAN- TO BUILD WHAT I CALL THE
ACADEMIC VILLAGE WHICH WILL BE
BLINDING. OTHERWISE STUDENT WITH
MEDICAL STUDENTS PHARMACY
STUDENT FEDERAL STUDENT NURSING
STUDENTS ARE IN A BROAD CAMPUS
PLAN- IN THE CENTER AND PART OF
SAN FRANCISCO. I AM FINALLY HAS
BEEN MENTIONED THE COLLEGES
WORKING WITH LEGISLATORS FROM
BOTH HOUSES- OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE IS ONE OF THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE YOU INTRODUCED
. TO CHANGE THE NAME OF THE
SCHOOL AND ALSO VERY IMPORTANTLY
TO ENDORSE THE SCHOOL'S
CONTINUING RESTORATIVE JUSTICE
WORK OF THE AFFECTED FIVE OF
ROUND VALLEY. I AND WITH THAT I
WILL TURN THE MICROPHONE OVER TO
MY YEAH OKAY. BUT STILL IT.
MISTER SORT WELCOME TO THE
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU VERY
SENATOR- THIS FALL UP ON MONDAY
VAGUE UNAIRED WE ARE PROCEEDING
ALL CYLINDERS GO TO CREATE A
BILL. IT HINGES ON PART WITH
OTHER INSTITUTIONS OF HIGHER
EDUCATION AND- IT LEADS THEM TO
OUR- EFFORTS TO EXPAND THAT
CONCEPT. BY SPEAKING FLOOD SB
ONE SIXTY NINE MONIES FOR THE
RENOVATION OF AN EXISTING
STUDENT HOUSING ASSET. THAT
ABSENCES RENOVATION WOULD NEED
TO BE A VACATED IS OUR OUR
PROPERTY AT ONE NINETY EIGHT
CALIFORNIA. I ONE HUNDRED
MCALISTER'S MADE IN NINETEEN
TWENTY NINE HIGH RISE- BUT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET DOES PROVIDE
US WITH THE RESOURCES TO
MAINTAIN CORE OPERATIONS WE
APPRECIATE OUR PARTNERSHIP WITH
THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION. AND THE OTHER
NOTEWORTHY ELEMENT THIS YEAR
IT'LL BE. OUR FIRST YEAR OF A
MODEST FEE INCREASE OF THREE
PERCENT- THE FIRST INCREASE IN
TEN YEARS A THIRD OF WHICH WE
DEDICATED TO FINANCIAL AID. AND
WITH THAT HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
AND BEFORE I ASK MY FIRST
QUESTION LET ME SAY THAT. THE
REASON WE HAVE A COMMITTEE
MEMBER ABSENT TODAY'S HE'S
TAKING THE BAR SO WE'RE HOPING
FOR A 100% THE SUBCOMMITTEE PASS
RIGHT TO BE ABLE TO. COMPETE
WITH YOURS- LET ME ASK A COUPLE
OF QUESTIONS AND ONE EITHER. TO
THE DINNER OR MR SEWARD. IT WAS
UNCLEAR FROM OUR AGENDA ITEMS
WHAT THE TIMING WAS ON THE NAME
CHANGE IS THAT. GOING TO BE
RECOMMENDED BEFORE THE MAY
REVISE IT BEFORE WE- WOULD HAVE
TO CONSIDER A LITTLE BIT TO
ACCOMMODATE WHATEVER THE COSTS
ARE OF THE NAME CHANGE. WE ARE
WORKING WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RAMOS ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIANG AND
WE'RE WORKING WITH SENATOR
WIENER- THERE'S A SPOT BILL THAT
WAS INTRODUCED IT AB NIGHT AB
NINETEEN THIRTY SIX. AS A PLACE
HOLDER- NEXT WEEK- I'LL BE IN
SACRAMENTO FOR A MEETING WITH
THE SELECT COMMITTEE ON NATIVE
AMERICAN AFFAIRS CHAIRED BY-
CENTER ARE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RAMOS- WE ANTICIPATE THAT SOME
TIME- HOPEFULLY SHORTLY AFTER
THAT- THE- LANGUAGE WILL BE
INTRODUCED- AND- RIGHT WOULD
TAKE OFF JUST CUT TOO SHORT JUST
BY SAYING. WE KNOW INTIMATELY
HOW SLOW BILLS MOVE SO. THAT
THAT ONE WOULD NOT BE ENACTED OR
SIGNED UP ON THAT TO GO INTO
EFFECT JANUARY FIRST AND SO WE
WOULD JUST HAVE TO FIGURE OUT.
WHAT TO DO BUT IT I'M NOT SURE
WILL KNOW BUT MAY REVISE IS WHAT
I WAS TRYING TO SAY. THAN EVER
AND I'M NOT SURE WHO TO ASK THIS
QUESTION BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE
ANYBODY FROM. UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA ON BUT- WHEN THE
LEGISLATURE AND GOVERNOR DID
THE- ALLOCATION FOR HOUSING.
THERE IS A CERTAIN AMOUNT FOR
USE CSU CAN COLLEGES DOES. THE
HOUSE. SKEWS ME THE HOUSING
PROJECT AT HASTINGS FALL UNDER
THE UC'S ALLOCATION FOR HOUSING. WE'VE GOT TO DO. THE ANSWER IS
SANDERS YES THE LEGISLATION-
THATAUTHORIZED THE ACT OF
PROVIDES FOR ALLOCATION FOR THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA AND
HASTINGS COLLEGE OF LAW SO WE
ARE PART IN PARCEL- INCLUDED IN
THE OF THE SENATE SIDE OR UC-
AND HASTINGS COLLEGE OF LAW DOES
NOT SPECIFY HOW THOSE FUNDS ARE
TO BE DISTRIBUTED THAT THE
LEGISLATURE WHAT IT REALLY MEANS
IS THEN AS YOU'RE SUBJECT TO THE
INTERNAL UC PRIORITIZATION. IS
THAT RIGHT NO THAT'S NOT
CORRECT- WE ARE SEPARATE BUDGET
BACK LINE ITEMS A WEEK COOPERATE
VERY CLOSELY WITH THE NUMBERS TO
CALIFORNIA WHAT WE DO NOT
ACCORDING EIGHT PERCENT. OF WHAT
WE HAVE. I THINK MAYBE MY
QUESTION WAS MISUNDERSTOOD
BECAUSE I ASKED THE FIRST
QUESTION OF WHETHER YOU ARE
INCLUDED IN THE UC ALLOCATION
AND THE ANSWER WAS YES. WAS THAT
NOT YES. WHAT DO I LIKE THAT I
THINK YOU SEE IS INCLUDED IN THE
A. L. SO THIS. I THINK THAT'S
THE REASON THIS IS NOT ON THIS
HEARING SO THAT THEY DIDN'T
HEAR. A. COMMENT SOMEBODY JUST.
WHERE IF I MADE A JACKSON BERMAN
FOR- I MEAN SEVENTY BASED
PROCESS AND I USED THINGS MAY
APPLY FOR. FROM THAT POOL IS. IN
UC'S. OUT OF BY- IF YOU. WE
ACTUALLY DO HAVE SOME THREE CELL
AND I'M STAY FOR TEN AND THE BE
ABLE PROVIDE INFORMATION. HERE
WE GO. THANK YOU CENTER LAYERED-
FORGIVEN MEDIA JUST- IF THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA DOES
NOT REVIEW THE YOU HACE CAPITAL
OUTLAY PROJECTS UNDER DE UM LAW
FOR THE HIGHER EDUCATION STUDENT
HOUSING GRANT FUND UC HASTINGS
AS PART OF THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA 20% BUT IT IS UP TO
THE LEGISLATURE TO CHOOSE WHICH
PROJECTS FROM THOSE THAT APPLIED
WILL BE FUNDED. MMHM. R. N. WHAT
WOULD BE DROPPED DOWN ON THAT.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN WITH REGARD
TO THE UC HASTINGS PROJECT. WHAT
IT MEANS SIR IS THAT- THERE'S
FOUR HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
AVAILABLE FOR BOTH UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA PROJECTS INK UC
HASTINGS- UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA HAS PUT FORWARD SIX
HUNDRED MILLION IN APPLICATIONS
AND UC HASTINGS HAS THEIR OWN
APPLICATIONS SO WHAT IT MEANS IS
THAT- WITH THE EXISTING AMOUNT
OF FUNDING. YOU CANNOT FUND ALL
PROJECTS SO YOU HAVE TO CHOOSE
BETWEEN THOSE VARIOUS PROJECTS.
I'M SORRY I STILL DON'T
UNDERSTAND IF. WHERE DOES UC
HASTINGS STAND IN THAT.
CURRENTLY THE ADMINISTRATION IS
MAKING ITS RECOMMENDATIONS TO BE
TENDERED TO THE LEGISLATURE
MARCH FIRST- WE WERE WAITING-
INSIGHTS AS TO HOW WE FARE THAT
THAT THE COMPETITIVE PROCESS. I
THINK I WOULD JUST MAKE A
STATEMENT GIVEN ALL THIS
DISCUSSION THAT. I THINK THIS
PROJECT IS VERY IMPORTANT TO
HASTINGS AND IT HAS BENEFITS
THAT ARE BEYOND JUST THE HOUSING
IN TERMS OF WHAT IT BRINGS AND
SO- I JUST DON'T KNOW HOW YOU
SEE DOES ITS INTERNAL SCORING
OR- HOWEVER I SAID BUT- I THINK
THIS PERSON WOULD LOOK VERY
FAVORABLY ON THIS AND WE JUST
HOPE THAT IT. COMPETES ARE WELL
WITHIN THE- UC SYSTEM BUT IT. I
DON'T THINK WE'RE GOING TO GET
ANY FURTHER ON THIS- I THINK
THAT'S THE BEST WE CAN DO AND
THEN- MAYBE WE ARE ONE LAST
QUESTION OF THE HASTINGS
REPRESENTATIVES AND THAT IS WITH
REGARD TO A TUITION INCREASE
FROM WHAT WE HAVE IN OUR PACKET
. ARE THE PERCENT AND THEN THAT
IT'S THE FIRST TIME IT'S BEEN
RAISED IN EIGHT OR TEN YEARS- HE
IS. ARE THERE ISSUES WITH THIS
ARE PEOPLE JUST RELIEVED THAT IT
HAS BEEN RAISED IN A NUMBER OF
YEARS AND HERE COMES OR- I HAVE
TO TAKE THAT SOME OF THEIR
EMPLOYEES. HEARD VERY LITTLE OF
CONCERN FROM OUR STUDENTS- THEY
ARE GRATEFUL THAT WE HAVEN'T
REYES TUITION AND TEN YEAR AND
WE'RE STILL ABOUT 12215% ABOVE
THE TUITION RATE FOR OUR SISTER
WAFFLES IN CALIFORNIA. OKAY
THANK YOU- THAT COMPLETES MY
QUESTION SIR ASSEMBLY ROADSHOW
BOGEY OF ANY QUESTIONS. NO
QUESTIONS SO OF LET ME JUST
THANK THE WITNESSES FOR BEING
HERE WE APPRECIATE IT I THINK WE%
ARE MENTIONED JUST SOME CONCERNS
FOR US BUT OTHERWISE THIS SEEMS-
TOGETHER SO THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE. OUR WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO
ISSUE NUMBER TWO WHICH IS THE
FIRST OF. SOME ISSUES WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE LIBRARY. AND
IT'S DIGIT DIGITIZATION OF
SIGNIFICANT MATERIALS WE HAVE ON
THE PANEL JENNIFER LOUIS FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE JASON
CONSTANT TOURISTS FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
AND GREG LUCAS THE CALIFORNIA
STATE LIBRARIAN ARE OUR WILL
TAKE THEM IN THAT ORDER- WELCOME
TO THE COMMITTEE JENNIFER LOW.
MISTER KAREN MEMBER DIRECTLY
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
AT THE STATE LIBRARY'S
AUGMENTATIONS IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET ARE A CONTINUATION OF THE
ADMINISTRATION'S EMPHASIS ON
ACCESS EQUITY AND INNOVATION.
AND A PART OF THAT SUBSTANTIAL
INVESTMENT FOR THE STATE LIBRARY
INCLUDES DIGITISATION OF
SIGNIFICANT MATERIALS FOR A
TOTAL OF FOURTEEN MILLION OF
WHICH TWELVE POINT SEVEN MILLION
AND ONE TIME GENERAL FUND AND
ONE POINT THREE FOUR MILLION IN
ONGOING JOURNAL FINE. WITH THE
ACTUAL COMPLETE WITH MY
PRESENTATION I'D BE HAPPY TO GO
INTO FURTHER DETAIL AS A
REQUEST- WE HAVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH A WOMAN
BOND. TO THE OHIO. SO IN OUR
VIEW THE PROPOSAL BEFORE YOU THE
DIGITIZATION PROPOSAL- IS
REASONABLE OF THE STATE'S
LIBRARIES CORE MISSION IS TO
PRESERVE HISTORICAL ASSETS AND
DIGITISATION FURTHERS THAT
MISSION BY FURTHER PRESERVING
THE ASSET AND MAKING IT
ACCESSIBLE WATER TRONIC THREE.
I'M NOT CERTAIN I WOULD DIRECT
YOUR ATTENTION TO PAGE EIGHT OF
YOUR AGENDA WHICH CONTAINS A
TABLE PROVIDING A MORE
INFORMATION ON THE EXACT
ACTIVITIES FUNDED UNDER THE
PROPOSAL. YOU CAN SEE THAT IT'S
A MULTI FACETED PROPOSAL IT
COVERS SEVERAL DIFFERENT
ACTIVITIES ONE THREE AGENCIES
TAKE ON MANY DIFFERENT
ACTIVITIES THERE'S ALWAYS A RISK
THAT- THEY FACE CERTAIN.
UNFORESEEN IMPLEMENTATION
ISSUES- SOMETIMES AT SPRINGS
DIFFICULTY MEETING THEIR
MILESTONES. I'M GIVEN THAT WE
RECOMMEND THAT YOU APPROVE THE
FUNDING APPROVED THE PROPOSAL-
BUT IN ADDITION ADOPTED
REPORTING LANGUAGE TO ASSIST
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT OVER THE
NEXT YEAR. THEN YOU SHOULD HAVE-
MANY OF THE KEY COMPONENTS WOULD
LAST OVER A FIVE YEAR PERIOD SO
WE RECOMMEND TWO REPORTS ONE
AROUND THE MIDDLE AND ONE
TOWARDS THE END. JUST ASSIST
WITH LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND WE'LL
MOVE ON TO THE STATE LIBRARIAN
WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE. THANK
YOU SENATOR GREG LUCAS
CALIFORNIA STATE LIBRARY- I
DON'T I DON'T HAVE ANYTHING TO
ADD A I THINK THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S SUGGESTION ABOUT
REPORTING IT THAT'S SOMETHING
WE'RE HAPPY TO DO. AND I THINK
IT'S- IT BE. A BENEFIT- NOT JUST
IN KEEPING THE LEGISLATURE
APPRISED OF OUR PROGRESS BUT- IT
HELPS US GET THERE TO. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND I HAD TWO
QUESTIONS AND YOU JUST ANSWERED
ONE SO THAT'S GREAT BECAUSE-
LET'S JUST DOES THE COMMITTEE
NOTE THERE SEEMS TO BE AGREEMENT
ON THE NOTION OF REPORTING AND
THAT WE MIGHT WANT TO DEAL WITH
THAT. LATER IN THE YEAR. END FOR
THE LIBRARY AND MY OTHER
QUESTION IS SOMEBODY THAT IS A-
FAMILY HISTORIAN THE ONE THING
THAT WAS UNCLEAR FROM THE AGENDA
MATERIALS IS. HOW WILL THE
DIGITIZED ITEMS BE MADE
AVAILABLE TO THE PUBLIC SO ONCE
THEY ARE DIGITIZED HOW WILL
THOSE ACT ACTUALLY BE AVAILABLE
TO PEOPLE. WHAT PRIMARILY
THROUGH THE STATE LIBRARY'S
CATALOG WHICH I THINK IF YOU
LOOK AT THE- THE SPREADSHEET
THAT JASON WAS JUST REFERRING TO
ON PAGE EIGHT. I MEAN ONE OF THE
FIRST THINGS WE HAVE TO DO IS
GET A CATALOG IN A POSITION
WHERE WE AND- HAVE IT. SORT OF
TOUCH ALL OF THE ITEMS THAT- BUT
OUR- ARE BEING HELD BY THE STATE
LIBRARY. OKAY SO I CAN I ANSWER
YOUR QUESTION YES BECAUSE
BASICALLY IF IT'S DIGITIZED IT'S
ADDED TO THE CATALOG AND A GOOD
KNOWLEDGE THIS DIGITIZED AND
THEN ANY MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC
CAN ACCESS YOUR CATALOG
COMMITTEE FRIGHT I MEAN THE FLIP
SIDE OF THAT IS SO FOR EXAMPLE
IF YOU GO TO THE STATE LIBRARY'S
WEBSITE AND YOU SEARCH THE
WEBSITE- AT THE MOMENT RIGHT YOU
MAY FIND THINGS THERE. RIGHT BUT
YOU WON'T FIND IN THE CATALOG
AND SO PART OF THIS PROCESS IS
SO FOR EXAMPLE IF YOU GO TO THE
CATALOG AND LOOK FOR THE STATE
LIBRARY'S DATABASE OF. EXECUTIVE
ORDERS AND PROCLAMATIONS- YOU
YOU MAY NOT FIND THAT RIGHT IN
THE CATALOG BUT YOU'LL FIND THAT
IN THE SEARCH BUT WEBSITE. SO
PART OF IT IS IT'S NOT EXACTLY
LIKE YOU KNOW EMERGENCY SERVICES
LOOKS AT IT BUT- PART OF IT IS
THIS IDEA OF INTER OPERABILITY
RIGHT SO IF YOU. I DO. SUPPORT
ON THE WEBSITE YOU CAN FIND AT
AND IF YOU SEARCH ON THE CATALOG
YOU CAN FIND WELL. I WOULD JUST
SUGGEST IS A FREQUENT USER OF
SUCH THINGS THAT SOMEHOW. IN THE
PROCESS A USER NEEDS TO TRIP
OVER A STATEMENT THAT SAYS.
SOMETHING'S ARMAMENT CATALOG DO
A KEYWORD SEARCH AND FIND
SOMETHING THAT PUTS THAT OUT
THERE AND SUGGESTED FOR THEM SO
THAT THEY KNOW. NO BIG DEAL IT'S
JUST. THE YOU KNOW. IT YOU AND I
HAVE TALKED- I DID A BILL I WAS
A DIAZ. OVER THE FACT THAT
SOMETHING LIKE 8210% OF WHAT'S
HELD IN THE STATE ARCHIVES.
WHICH IS NOT UNDER YOUR
JURISDICTION. ARE HELD IN THE
STATE ARCHIVES WAS WAS
CONFIDENTIAL AND CLOSE TO THE
PUBLIC AND IT TURNED OUT TO BE.
PRISON RECORDS FROM THE EIGHTEEN
HUNDREDS SOME CIVIL WAR PENSIONS
MENTAL HEALTH RECORDS. THINGS
WERE THE PERSON INVOLVED AND
THEIR CHILDREN PROBABLY HAD LONG
SINCE DIED IF NOT GRANDCHILDREN
AND SODA THE CONCERN FOR
CONFIDENTIALITY WAS WIFE. INDEED
IT IS THE BILL ALLOWED THE
ARCHIVIST OPEN THESE AND SO THEY
WERE OPENING- AND DIGITIZING
THEM. IN A WAY THAT THEY WERE
OUT ON THE WEBSITE YOU COULD
KEYWORD SEARCH BY NAME YOU COULD
FIND A AND IT WAS A WAY IF YOU
WERE DOING RESEARCH ON YOUR
FAMILY THAT. THAT YOU CAN GET IT
OUT THERE IN IN A WAY THAT
PEOPLE COULD ACCESS SO. THAT'S
ALL ON. DRUGS IT'S NO BIG DEAL.
JUST I WOULD HOPE THAT PEOPLE
WOULDN'T HAVE TO KNOW. CERTAIN
THANKS TO GO DEEP INTO A TO FIND
SOMETHING THAT WOULD BE OF
INTEREST TO THEM SO JUST.
THROUGH THAT FILTER. BUT THIS IS
A GREAT PROJECT I STRONGLY
SUPPORTED. I'M GLAD THAT YOU
AGREED TO THE- REPORTED. A
CENTER- TROUBLE. ANY QUESTIONS
ON THIS ONE. JUST THE PERSON
SAYS HERE- TO CELEBRATE HAVING
IDEA AND THE TIMELINE FOR
ROLLING OUT THE GOVERNOR'S.
PROPOSAL. IT'S SET MY
RECOLLECTION I I'LL DOUBLE CHECK
FOR YOU BUT MY RECOLLECTION IS
THAT IT'S OVER A FOUR YEAR
PERIOD. SO THERE'S IT'S SHEARED
RIGHT THERE'S ACTIVITIES THAT
BEGAN IN THE FIRST YEAR AND THEN
THERE'S ONES THAT SORT OF
CARRIED THROUGH FOR THE NEXT
FOUR YEARS. SO IT'S ONE TIME
MONEY THAT'S PARCELED OUT OVER A
FOUR YEAR PERIOD. OKAY AND-
BECAUSE THE LINE WOULD BE
STARTING ON JULY FIRST OR JULY
SECOND PROBABLY BUT- I MEAN IT'S
OVER FOR YOUR- WONDERFUL THANK
YOU AND THEN MY FOLLOW UP
QUESTION WOULD BE FROM LAST
YEAR'S I KNOW THAT- I WAS TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT THIS MORNING THE
ALLOCATION OF THE FUNDS THAT
WERE GIVEN TO THE STATE LIBRARY
LAST YEAR. WAS IT. TWO BILLION
DOLLARS OR WAS IT ONE BILLION
DOLLARS. THE FUNDING THAT WENT
TO THE STATE IRIS LAST YEAR AND
I WANTED TO JUST CAN I GET AN
UPDATE AS TO- THE PROGRESS THAT
HAD BEEN MADE WITH THAT WITH
THOSE FUNDS AND HOW THEY HAVE
BEEN UTILIZED THIS PAST YEAR.
WELL IF WE IF WE HAD GOTTEN TWO
BILLION DOLLARS OR OR ONE
BILLION DOLLARS- I WOULD HAVE
QUICKLY DECLARED VICTORY AND
RETIRED- FIGURE OUT THE AMOUNT
THE EXACT AMOUNT AND I WAS
TALKING TO MY- CONSULTANT AT
THAT DO YOU REMEMBER THE AMOUNT.
IT CORRECT ME I. SENATOR NOW WE
KNOW THAT THAT IF YOU PUT THAT
AMOUNT AND YOU CAN GET HIM TO
RETIRE. PROBABLY THE MORE
SIGNIFICANT. LEADS US. WHERE TO
THAT- SENATORS SO THE BALL OF
THE MONEY THAT CAME TO THE STATE
LIBRARY LAST YEAR WAS- ABOUT
FOUR HUNDRED AND THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS. THAT'S EARMARKED FOR-
KIND OF LIFE SAFETY DIRE NEED
IMPROVEMENTS TO LOCAL LIBRARY
FACILITIES AROUND STATE. AND
THERE'S AT THE END OF OUR
SECTION THERE'S- THERE'S A
SECTION THAT GOES THROUGH TRYING
TO FIND THE PAGE FOR YOU- EIGHT
SEVENTEEN ON MY AGENDA IT TALKS
ABOUT ALL THE VARIOUS PROGRAMS
THAT THE LIBRARY RECEIVED MONEY
FOR AND- I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU HAVE ON THOSE I
SENT A MEMO AS WELL TOO-
COMMITTEE LAST NIGHT THAT KIND
OF TOUCHES ON MAN THE NEXT BEST
AVAILABLE AS WELL. IS THERE A
SPECIFIC ONE- NO I WILL REVIEW
SO LET ME JUST FOR THE RECORD
COMPLETELY NOT ONE OR TWO BILL
BILLION DOLLARS. SO WHAT. I
GUESS WE'LL JUST HAVE TO. ARGUE
THAT THEY CAN BE GOING HE SAID
THIS IS ONE THAT WE WON'T GET AN
ANSWER TO YOU OFFLINE OKAY
PERFECT WOULD IT BE POSSIBLE TO
OFFER SOME ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION TO THE COMMITTEE.
ALWAYS THE LAST ONE UP AGAINST A
DOUBLE- I JUST DID ARE THERE WAS
A QUESTION ABOUT THIS PROGRAM
THE DIGITIZATION PROPOSAL OVER
HOW MANY YEARS I DO WANT TO
POINT OUT THAT IT'S A THERE ARE
THERE ARE SOME ELEMENTS THAT ARE
OVER A MULTI YEAR PERIOD AS
REGULATED TO. OTHERS A SMALL
COMPONENT THAT'S ONGOING SO
THERE ARE SOME ONGOING POSITIONS
THAT ARE FUNDED YOU CAN SEE THAT
AGAIN ON THE ON THE TABLE ON
PAGE EIGHT- THERE ARE SEVERAL
ACTIVITIES THAT WOULD HAVE SORT
OF PERMANENT POSITION SO THAT
WOULD BE ONGOING AND THEN THERE
ARE A SOMEONE TIME FUNDS THAT
WOULD JUST BE ONE TIME JUST AND
THE BUDGET YEAR. SO IT'S A
COMBINATION OF DIFFERENT
ACTUALLY USE BUT YOU COULD THINK
OF THEM. I AM VERY FOCUSED THE-
PROPOSAL'S REALLY BEING OVER A
FIVE YEAR INITIAL FIVE YEAR
PERIOD. AND THEN THERE WAS A
QUESTION AS TO HOW MUCH FUNDING
THE STATE LIBRARY RECEIVED AND I
DON'T HAVE THE EXACT AMOUNT IN
FRONT OF ME BUT IT WAS ABOUT SIX
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS- MOTION
WHICH WAS ONE TIME FUNDING- THE
BIGGEST PROPOSAL WAS FOR LIBRARY
INFRASTRUCTURE GRANTS. I WAS
ABOUT FOUR HUNDRED THIRTY
MILLION AND THEN THERE THERE IS
AN ADDITIONAL HUNDRED OR SOME
MILLION FOR OTHER LOCAL
INITIATIVES AND ON AN ISSUE SIX
YOU'RE GOING TO ACTUALLY GET
IMPLEMENTATION UPDATE ON ALL
THESE ACTIVITIES TO SEE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY HERE. IN A FEW MUCH
YOU'RE SAYING IS SHE HAS ANOTHER
BITE AT THE APPLE. PRESS OKAY
THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS
. GREG LUCAS AGAIN I'M I'M JUST
LOOKING AT THE FIRST PAGE OF THE
STATE LIBRARY SECTION HERE IN
THE AGENDA- IT SAYS FOR A STATE
LIBRARY EXPENDITURES TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO. SIX
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY ONE. MILLION
EIGHT HUNDRED AND THIRTY SEVEN
DOLLARS. SO YES SENATOR NOT A
BILLION. AND ONE HUNDRED THIRTY
SIX OR A TWO THIRDS OF THE WAY
THERE. OKAY WELL THANKS CLARIFY
CENTER THAT THAT POOL OF FUNDS-
THAT WAS PREVIOUSLY REFERENCES
AVAILABLE FOR FIVE YEARS I READ
THE BOOK THANK YOU. OKAY WE
APPRECIATE EVERYBODY'S OUR
COMMENTS WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO
ISSUE NUMBER THREE AT THE
LIBRARY ONLINE JOB TRAINING AND
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AND
INTERESTINGLY IT'S EXACTLY THE
SAME PANEL SO WHAT LET'S BEGIN
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
HELLO AGAIN MISTER CHAIR AND A
MEMBER JENNIFER WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. AS THE
STATE LIBRARIES- ASIANS FOR THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET TOTALS TWENTY
ONE POINT FIVE MILLION AND
WITHIN THAT ONE TIME- OF
MEDITATION IS THE ONLINE JOB
TRAINING AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT WHICH COMPOSES OF
EIGHT POINT EIGHT MILLION A ONE
TIME GENERAL FUND. WHICH IS A
CONTINUATION OF ONLINE UP
SKILLING AND PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT SERVICES TO LOCAL
LIBRARY PATRONS CURRENTLY
SUPPORTED BY FUNDS FROM THE
FEDERAL AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN ACT
OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUT THAT I
SHALL CONCLUDE MY PRESENTATION
AND HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND I KNOW I HAVE A QUESTION OF
A- L. A. O. WE- WON. A
REASONABLE WAY TO VIEW THIS
PROPOSAL IS TO TREAT IT AS A
PILOT SO CURRENTLY THE STATE
LIBRARY. IS SPENDING FOUR POINT
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS. OF FEDERAL
RELIEF FUNDS ON- LIBRARY BASE
WRKFORCE DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS-
THIS PROPOSAL WOULD EXTEND THAT
FOR AN ADDITIONAL TWO YEARS FOR
THAT WHAT WHAT USING GENERAL
FUND SO THAT WOULD GIVE. THREE
YEARS OF ACTIVITY THAT THE
LEGISLATURE COULD THEN EVALUATE
. SO THE QUESTION IN OUR MIND IS
THIS A INITIATIVE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE THINGS IS PROMISING
IS WORTH PILOTING. AND WE THINK
THE KEY CHALLENGE HERE IS THAT
BECAUSE THE INITIATIVE IS STILL
IN ITS FIRST YEAR OF OPERATION
IT'S DIFFICULT TO GAUGE THAT-
THE STATE LIBRARY STILL
COLLECTING INFORMATION ON THE
NUMBER OF PATRONS WHO ARE
PARTICIPATING. PATRON
DEMOGRAPHICS UPDATE PARTICIPANT
OUTCOMES IN THESE PROGRAMS
THAT'S DIFFICULT TO ASSESS THE
EFFECTIVENESS AND THE OVERALL
IMPACT. THE STATE LIBRARY DID
PROVIDE US ONE HE MEASURE WHICH
IS THE NUMBER OF COURSE HOURS-
COMPLETED THUS FAR- WHICH THEY
ESTIMATE WHICH THEY SAID WAS
OVER TWENTY THOUSAND COURSE
HOURS- GAUGE. THEY SORT OF
IMPACT OF THAT WE CONVERTED THAT
USING A SORT OF A FULL TIME
EQUIVALENT BASIS IT'S A SIMILAR
APPROACH WE USE FOR THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. I GOT AN
ESTIMATE OF ABOUT FORTY FULL
TIME EQUIVALENT PARTICIPANTS.
NOW WOULD SUGGEST A AVERAGE COST
ABOUT OVER A HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER FULL TIME EQUIVALENT
PARTICIPATE WHICH IS QUITE A BIT
HIGHER THAN WHAT THE STATE
PROVIDES TO THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. NOW HE INITIATIVE
STILL ONGOING SO IT'S LIKELY
THAT MORE COURSE HOURS WILL BE
COMPLETED. BUT AGAIN BECAUSE OF
THE LACK OF SORT OF THE DATA AND
SOME OF THE UNCERTAINTY AROUND
THE NUMBER OF COURSE HOURS WE
THINK IT'S A BIT PREMATURE TO BE
SUPPORTING THIS INITIATIVE AT
THIS. TIME WE RECOMMEND
REJECTING THE PROPOSAL. ONE
OTHER POINT I'D LIKE TO.
REJECTED THE PROPOSAL WOULD NOT
BE THE FINAL WORD ON IT.
FOLLOWING THE STATE LIBRARY
CONSOLE THE MINISTER IT'S
FEDERAL FUNDING COULD STILL
IMPLEMENT THE PROGRAM COLLECTED
ON IT. THEY WERE TO COLLECT A
LOT OF THE DATA THAT ADDRESSES
MANY OF OUR CONCERNS. THE STATE
LIBRARY COULD RETURN THE
LEGISLATURE TO FUTURE YOUR- AND
REQUEST FUNDING FOR IT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NOW WE'LL MOVE ON
TO THE STATE WEBER. IT'S GREAT
WORKERS FROM THE STATE LIBRARY.
UP. I GUESS THE SHORT ANSWER IS
THAT WE REQUESTED THE ADDITIONAL
FUNDING TO CREATE A PERIOD OF
TIME WHERE WE COULD BETTER
ASSESS THE PROGRAM'S EFFICACY
AND HOW MANY PEOPLE WERE USING
IT AND OVER A THREE YEAR PERIOD
BE ABLE TO ON AN ANNUAL OR EVEN
A SEMI ANNUAL BASIS FINE TUNE
WHAT'S BEING PROVIDED. WHAT WE
FOUND SO FAR IN THE REASON WE
SUBMITTED THE BUDGET REQUEST IS-
THANK THANKS ENERGY MAY BE TOO
STRONG A WORD BUT NEW
PARTNERSHIPS THAT HAVE- MERCH
BETWEEN LOCAL WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT- COMMITTEES AND JOB
CENTRES SAY I MEAN THE STORY I
ENJOYED COMES FROM ANAHEIM.
WHERETHE THEIR JOB SANDERS SAID
MY GOD YOU KNOW NOW WE HAVE
THESE ALL OF THESE SERVICES
AVAILABLE TO THE PEOPLE TO COME
AND VISIT US WE WOULD NEVER BE
ABLE TO AFFORD THIS ON OUR OWN.
AND THAT'S WHY WE ASK FOR THE
ADDITIONAL TWO YEARS IS TO DO
SOME OF THE THINGS THAT JASON
WAS SUGGESTED IT IS JUST WAS
GIVING WAS SUGGESTING WHICH IS
TO GET A BETTER DETERMINATION OF
HOW IT WORKS. ONE YEAR ISN'T
REALLY ENOUGH TO. OKAY DOES THAT
COMPLETE YOUR COMMENTS YES SEVEN
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE
APPRECIATED AND I THINK THAT.
THAT MY ONE QUESTION WAS GOING
TO BEAT S. FOR RESPONSE TO THE
L. A. OWES OUR COMMENTS AND I
THINK THAT THAT'S JUST WHAT THE
STATE LIBRARY DID SO- ARE
CONSIDERED AND MAY LET ME ASK
CENTER ACCIONES BIOGRAPHY OF ANY
QUESTIONS. SO WITH THE WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT I KNOW WE HAVE A LOT
OF LOCAL COMMUNITY SCHOOLS AND-
TRADE SCHOOLS ARE HEADING IN
THAT IN THAT. SPACE WITH THE
LIBRARY COMING INTO WANTED TO DO
SOMETHING THAT ARE ON THAT END
ARE YOU FOLKS LOOKING TO
COMPLEMENT THE LOCAL PROGRAMS
ARE YOU FOLKS LOOKING INTO BEING
YOUR OWN PROGRAM. SORRY SENATORS
MUTED MYSELF- OUR GOAL IS TO
COMPLEMENT AND PARTNER WITH
LOCAL PROGRAMS THAT'S WHERE THE
GREATEST SUCCESS SO FAR IN THE
EARLY MONTHS OF EMPLOYING
IMPLEMENTING THIS HAVE COME
FROM. AND ADDITIONALLY- OVER THE
OVER THE YEAR OF THE PANDEMIC
MANY MORE PEOPLE ARE ENTERING
LIBRARIES THROUGH THE DIGITAL
DOORWAY RIGHT THEN THEN THE
PHYSICAL DOORWAY. AND SO AN AREA
WHERE THE STATE CAN BE OF HELP
IS AN STATEWIDE CONTRACTS OR
STATEWIDE SUBSCRIPTIONS LIKE
THIS WHERE WE CAN MAKE THINGS
AVAILABLE EQUALLY TO ALL
LIBRARIES. AND ALLOW OLD PEOPLE
WHO FOR WHATEVER REASON- HAVE
FALLEN OUT OF THE WORK FORCE
BECAUSE OF THE PANDEMIC THEY CAN
ACCESS THESE MATERIALS- FROM
THEIR HOME AS WELL AS GOING TO A
LOCAL JOBCENTRE LOCAL WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT- COMMITTEE S. AS
YOU'RE DESCRIBING. OKAY AND DO
YOU HAVE THE STUFF TO BE ABLE
TO- PROVIDE THIS PROGRAM THE
SERVICES. SORRY I'M NOT I'M NOT
SURE I UNDERSTAND YOUR QUESTION
IN ORDER TO SO ONE OF THE
CONCERNS THAT WE HAVE- WITH MANY
OF THE- AB SCHOOLS THAT WE'VE
BEEN HEARING FROM IS THE FACT
THAT WE'RE- WE'RE GIVING THEM A
LOT OF- MONIES. FUNDING TO BE
ABLE TO PROVIDE CERTAIN PROGRAMS
BUT THAT THE CHALLENGE LIES IN.
HAVING THE ACTUAL STAFF
DETERMINED THESE PROGRAMS SO MY
QUESTION TO YOU WOULD BE. DO YOU
HAVE THE CAPACITY TO BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE THESE- THESE PROGRAMS IN
IN THESE RESOURCES. YES THE
SHORT ANSWER IS YES- I MEAN THIS
PROPOSAL DOESN'T COME WITH
ADDITIONAL PERSONNEL FOR THE
STATE LIBRARY. BUT ONE OF THE
TERRIFIC THINGS ABOUT- I MEAN
SOME OF THESE. SOME OF THE ITEMS
THAT ARE IN THIS PLATFORM OR
THIS CAFETERIA RIGHT OF. YOU
KNOW JOB JOB SKILLS JOB TRAINING
JOB DEVELOPMENT BUT THINGS LIKE
LINKED IN LEARNING COURSE THERE
THERE'S A VARIETY OF DIFFERENT
THINGS WHICH ARE. EASILY
ACCESSIBLE TO ANYONE SO
PRIMARILY BY THE. SORT OF A YOU
KNOW THE PERSONNEL ASPECT IS
AND- HELPING SOMEBODY FIND WHAT
IT IS THEY'RE LOOKING FOR IF
THEY CAN'T FIND IT THEMSELVES IS
PRIMARILY A SELF SERVICE SORT
OF. CONCEPT SO THE WINDY WAY OF
SAYING YES WE HAVE THE- NOW TO
BE ABLE TO PUT THIS OUT TO EVERY
LOCAL LIBRARY. THANK YOU THANK
YOU THE COMPLETE YOUR QUESTION
YES THANK YOU. IT AND LET ME
JUST NOTE THAT I KNOW THE STATE
LIBRARIAN WORKS OUT OF THE
CUBICLES ON JUST TO THIRTIES
FOUND THE BACKGROUND. CHECKS
HAVE THE STATURE THE- ISSUE. OF
LET'S MOVE TO ISSUE NUMBER FOUR
WHICH IS LUNCH AT THE LIBRARY
AND FASCINATINGLY WE HAVE THE
EXACTLY THE SAME PANEL SO LET'S
BEGIN WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. HELLO JENNIFER LOUIS
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE-
THE STATE LIBRARY'S
AUGMENTATION- FOR ON GOING TO
FIND TOTAL IS EIGHT POINT FIVE
MILLION IN GENERAL FUND. WHICH
WITHIN THE SET AMOUNT TO AT
LUNCH AT THE LIBRARY IS PROVIDE
FOR FIVE MILLION ONGOING GENERAL
FUND AND WITHIN THAT THE
AUGMENTATION FOUR POINT SEVEN
MILLION WILL GO TOWARDS LOCAL
SYSTEMS TO SUPPORTING MUCH OF
THE LIBRARY. I WITH THAT I.
SHALL CONCLUDE MY PRESENTATION
I'LL BE HAPPY TO GO INTO ANY
FURTHER DETAILS- AS REQUESTED OR
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL
MOVE TO THE LA OF. THIS PROPOSAL
ADDRESSES A VERY SALIENT ISSUE
WHICH IS A FOOD INSECURITY AMONG
CHILDREN. AND IT AIMS TO ADDRESS
THAT BY INCREASING PARTICIPATION
IN THE FEDERAL SUMMER MEALS
PROGRAM. GRAHAM OF PROVIDES A
FEDERALLY FUNDED MEALS TO
STUDENTS AT VERY STATE SITES
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA THIS
PROPOSAL SPECIFICALLY FOCUSES
ON- ESTABLISHING MORE LIBRARY
SITES THAT ARE PARTICIPATING IN
THE FEDERAL SUMMER MEALS PROGRAM
. THIS IS A REASONABLE- OVERALL
OBJECTIVE BUT WE HAVE THREE
CONCERNS THE FIRST CONCERN AS A
CONCERNED YOU PRODUCE REYES IN
PAST YEARS WHICH IS THAT THE
PROPOSAL IN QUESTION IS A-
FAIRLY NARROW APPROACH TO
ADDRESS A SUMMER STUDENT
SECURITY. THE PROPOSAL
SPECIFICALLY FOCUSES ON CREATING
MORE LIBRARY SITES EVEN THOUGH
MANY KINDS OF SITES CAN QUALIFY
TO DELIVER- FEDERAL SUMMER MEALS
. I'M THINKING USUALLY WANT TO
RAISE IS THAT- SOME OTHER STATE
ACTIVITIES COULD RESULT IN.
INCREASING PARTICIPATION IN THE
FEDERAL SUMMER MEALS PROGRAM.
FOR EXAMPLE THE STATE IS
CURRENTLY. IMPLEMENTING THE
EXPANDED LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES
PROGRAM WHERE YOU WALK. WHICH
SUPPORTS MORE AFTERSCHOOL AND
SUMMER LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES AT
SCHOOLS BECAUSE STUDENTS WOULD
BE ATTENDING- SCHOOLS DURING THE
SUMMER- IT FOR PARTS OF THE
SUMMER THAT WAY THAT COULD
RESULT IN AND I'M MORE
PARTICIPATION AND FEDERAL
SOMEONE YELLS. EXACT IMPACT OF
THAT IS HARD TO. GAUGE AT THIS
MOMENT. AND THE THIRD ISSUE WE
WANT TO RAISES AND THIS IS A
COMMON YOU'LL HEAR IS MAKE FOR A
LOT OF THE PROPOSALS- IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. THE PROPOSAL
COMES WITH VERY FEW STATUTORY
PARAMETERS ACCORDING LANGUAGE OR
AN EVALUATION OF THE PROGRAM-
GIVEN THESE FACTORS WE HAVE WE
RECOMMEND TWO MODIFICATIONS TO
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL. THE
FIRST IS WE RECOMMEND NARROWING
THE SCOPE OF IT AND MAKING THE
PROPOSAL LIMITED TERMS. OF FOR
EXAMPLE WE SUGGEST. PERHAPS
PROVIDING FIVE MILLION THAT
COULD BE SPENT OVER THREE YEARS
- THAT WOULD ALLOW THE
LEGISLATURE TO BETTER SISTER THE
IMPACT OF THE AUGMENTATION TO
THE LUNCH OF LIBRARY PROGRAMS.
BUT ALSO ALLOW THE LEGISLATURE
FEW YEARS TO ASSESS THE IMPACT
OF OTHER ACTIVITIES LIKE YOU
WALK AND- ASING SUMMER MEAL
PARTICIPATION. OUR M. ALERT
ACRONYM ALERT EXPANDED LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES I'M SORRY SENATOR
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THEIR- FOR
NOW. AND THEN THE SECOND
MODIFICATION WE RECOMMEND. WOULD
BE TO ADOPT MORE STATUTORY
GUIDANCE BECAUSE HOUSING
PARAMETERS OVER HOW THE FUNDS TO
BE SPENT ASTONISHING REPORTING
LANGUAGE- AND REQUIRING
EVALUATION OF PROGRAM WOULD BE
HAPPY TO WORK WITH STAFF ON SOME
OF THE TECHNICAL ASPECTS ABOUT
IT MORE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ARE THEN WE'LL MOVE ON TO THE
STATE BY BURNT. GREG LUCAS FROM
THE STATE LIBRARY- YOU KNOW I.
ME PERSONALLY AT THE STATE
LIBRARY AND A LOT OF LOCAL
LIBRARIANS- ARE ARE VERY
PASSIONATE ABOUT THIS PROGRAM
AND THANK YOU KNOW. I THINK WHAT
IT SAYS FOOD INSECURITY IS A
SALIENT ISSUE I MEAN THAT
UNDERSTATES IT A LITTLE BIT-
THERE'S THREE MILLION KIDS IN
CALIFORNIA WHO ARE ELIGIBLE FOR-
YOU KNOW FREE OR SUBSIDIZED
SCHOOL LUNCHES. AND ACCORDING TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION 11%
OF THEM ARE GETTING MAIL IN THE
SUMMER. AND IF YOU'RE HUNGRY YOU
CAN'T ALERT. AND THIS THIS MAY
BE I FORGOT WHAT THAT LED
CHANNELS THING IS. IS THAT AN
INCREMENTAL OR NOT A GLOBAL
APPROACH BUT IT IS SOMETHING
THAT'S BEING DONE TO TRYING TO
ADDRESS THIS. AND THE INCREASE
THAT'S PROPOSED IN THE BUDGET
ALSO ALLOWS THE LIBRARY TWO ONE.
THE HAVE SOMEBODY DEVOTED TO
THIS PROGRAM FULL TIME TO HELP
LOCAL LIBRARIES DO THE THINGS
THAT MAKE THIS PROGRAM A SUCCESS
AND- HELP PROVIDE MEALS AND
OTHER FOOD SITES WHICH IS. TO
CREATE PARTNERSHIPS WITH LOCAL
FOOD BANKS WHICH IS TO CREATE.
SYSTEMS WHERE WHEN A SCHOOL
DISTRICT CLOSES RIGHT BAY HAND
OFF THE BATON TO THE LOCAL
LIBRARY OR THE BOYS AND GIRLS
CLUB I MEAN THEY DO A LOT OF
SUMMER. MEALS AS WELL THE IDEA
HERE IS TO TRY AND IMPROVE THE-
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF MEALS
THAT ARE BOWING TO HUNGRY KIDS
IS THIS THE ANSWER NOW. I MEAN
LAST YEAR THE LEGISLATURE ENDED
UP PASSED IN THE GOVERNOR SIGNED
A BILL THAT SAYS. ANY KID WHO'S
HUNGRY DURING THE SCHOOL YEAR
GETS A MEAL. AND FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS IS DEVOTED TO
THAT IN THE EDUCATION BUDGET
ALONG WITH A HUNDRED AND FORTY
FIVE MILLION TO MAKE. KITCHEN
IMPROVEMENTS TO THE PUBLIC
SCHOOLS TO ACCOMMODATE THAT SO
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE- FEELS LIKE
AN ONGOING. APPROPRIATE OF FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS TO HELP FEED
MORE THAN RIGHT THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND OF THE THREE MILLION
KIDS YOU SHOULD BE EATING MEALS
DURING THE SUMMER IT ISN'T THAT-
THE NORMAL SEVEN INVESTMENT.
WITH RESPECT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
END UP LET ME JUST MAKE A
COMMENT BOB THE FORCE IF THERE'S
OTHER QUESTIONS IN THE COMMENT
AS I WAS TELLING THE STAFF
DURING THE BRIEFING THAT WHEN I
WAS IN THE ASSEMBLY AND WAS
BUDGET CHAIR. R. EVERY YEAR THAT
AWAY ALL LEGISLATIVE ANALYST
WOULD COME TO US AND SAY WE WANT
TO INCREASE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
FEES SAID EVERY YEAR I'D SAY NO
WHAT WHAT WE'RE NOT GONNA DO
THAT BY. THE WAY- ONE YEAR CAME
IN A WITH THE SPEAKER AND I. AND
SAID IN A RECOMMENDATION THAT'S
GOING TO MAKE JOHN WANT TO THROW
UP. ONCE AGAIN WE WANT TO RAISE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE FEES IT AND-
AND WEBER AND SO I REALLY TRULY
APPRECIATE THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST IN THEIR ROLE AND EVERY
YEAR THEY MAKE A RUN AT THIS
PROGRAM AND I THINK. THE FACT
THAT IT'S HERE'S JUST A
STATEMENT THAT WERE COMMITTED TO
IT. AND WE WANT TO KEEP GOING SO
I THINK THAT'S JUST WHERE WE ARE
IN TOUCH WITH ME S. SENATE WROTE
SHOWBOAT. IF YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS AND SHE HAS. NO
QUESTION SO LET ME THANK
EVERYBODY. FOR THEIR CAR ON THAT
AND THEN WE'LL MOVE TO ISSUE
SIX- WHICH IS LIBRARY BUILDING
RENTAL COSTS AND- AND IT'S THE
SAME PANEL WILL BEGIN WITH OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. HELLO
JENNIFER LOUIS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AS PART OF
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ON GOING
ON VACATION TO SUPPORT THE STATE
LIBRARY- WERE. PROPOSING
INCREASED RENTAL COSTS- FOR THE
LIBRARY COURTS BUILDING A QUEUE
OF TWO POINT TWO MILLION ONGOING
GENERAL FUND SUPPORT TO THE
STATE OPERATIONS FOR THE STATE
LIBRARY. WITH THE ACTUAL
COMPLETE MY PRESENTATION AND
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THANK YOU MOVED TO THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST. NO CONCERNS
ON THIS PROPOSAL WE RECOMMEND
YOU APPROVE THE FUNDS GREAT
THANK YOU AND THEN WE'LL MOVE ON
TO THE STATE LIBRARY- THAT'S
GREAT- BECAUSE FROM THE STATE
LIBRARY THAT. THAT'S YOUR HONOR
WHAT I THINK ABOUT IT NO WE'RE
HAPPY TO KEEP YOU IN CUBICLES.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH- WILL
MOVE TO A AND I DON'T THINK WE
HAVE ANY PROBLEMS THERE'S NO
QUESTION. ON THIS. ONE ISSUE
NUMBER SIX THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE BUDGET ACT AGREEMENT THIS IS
ONE THAT WE JUMP TO A LITTLE BIT
EARLIER. IT'S A OVERSIGHT IN THE
ONE PERSON TO SPEAK ON MRS OF
THE STATE LIBRARY SO MR WORKERS
. TELL ME HOW YOU LIKE ME TO
PROCEED- I SENT A MEMO LAST
NIGHT THAT SORT OF SUMMARIZES
THE COMMITTEE THAT THE KIND OF
pEACH OF THESE PROGRAMS. I CAN GO
THROUGH THEM IN THE ORDER THEY
ARE LISTED AND BRIEFLY SUMMARIZE
THAT I THINK. THAT THE MATERIAL
IS SELF EXPLANATORY IF YOU COULD
JUST GO THROUGH A NAME EACH ONE
A DO A SENTENCE OR TWO ABOUT IT
THAT'S MAYBE A GOOD WAY TO JUST
SUMMARIZE IT AND YEAH. HAPPY TO
HAVE QUESTIONS. SENATOR OCHO
BOGUE LEFT THE ROOM TEMPORARILY
AND- IN A SENTENCE OR TWO ABOUT
EACH ONE MIGHT ALLOW HER TO BE
BACK IN TIME FOR QUESTIONS. OKAY
WELL THE FIRST ONE IS THE
LIBRARY INFRASTRUCTURE GRANT
PROGRAM- FOUR HUNDRED AND THIRTY
NINE MILLION. WE CONDUCTED- WHAT
WE CALL A PRE APPLICATION
PROCESS LAST FALL IN SEPTEMBER.
THE TRYING TO GAUGE WHAT THE-
NEED WAS OUT THERE THE DEMAND-
AND SEE IF THERE WAS ANYTHING
THAT HAVEN'T BEEN ANTICIPATED-
IN THE BUDGET BILL IN TERMS OF
SPENDING WE RECEIVED SEVENTY
THREE APPLICATIONS- OF WHICH-
SIXTY WERE FOR BUILDINGS THAT
ARE- EIGHTY EIGHT AMERICANS
WITH. DISABILITIES ACT COMPLIANT
- WHICH WAS SURPRISING TO US-
AND IS. AN AREA WHERE NEITHER
REALLY THE STATE NOR THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT PROVIDES FUNDS TO
ASSIST LOCAL JURISDICTIONS IN
MEETING THOSE REQUIREMENTS. AND
ACTUALLY THAT WAS THE MAJOR ONE
SO WANTED TO JUST- ALLUDE TO THE
LIBRARY BROADBAND TO DOUBLE
BROADBAND ARE WORKING WITH THE
OUTFIT CALLED CTC ENERGY AND
TECHNOLOGY WHICH IS A THIRD
PARTY AGGREGATORS THE STATE HAS
THE STATE LIBRARY HAS ENTITY BUT
WORKS WITH US IN OUR
RELATIONSHIP WITH SCENIC WHICH
THE STATE HAS NOW CONTRACTED
WITH TO DO THIS NEW MIDDLE MILE
WORK THAT'S GOING ON AND SO
THEY'VE BEEN WORKING WITH US TO
TRY AND FIND BEES PROJECTS THAT
THE THIS POT OF MONEY IS
DESIGNED TO ENCOURAGE AND THOSE
ARE. PROJECTS IN WHICH- YOU
CONNECT AS PART OF ONE PROJECT
AT LEAST A SCHOOL AT LEAST A
LIBRARY PROVIDE TELEHEALTH AND
WHERE WHERE WE CAN- INCLUDED
TRIBAL NATION EACH OF THOSE
ENTITIES GETS A FEDERAL
DISCOUNT. AND SO USING THIS
MONEY TO ALSO MAKE A DOWN
PAYMENT OR A MATCHES WHAT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT CALLS IT.
ALLOWS A LOT OF PROJECTS ARE OUR
EXPERIENCE IS BANNED. IN
PARTNERSHIPS WITH SCHOOLS ON
THINGS LIKE THIS IT ALLOWS
PROJECTS THAT PREVIOUSLY WEREN'T
BEING BID ON THE LAST MILE TO
GET MORE INTEREST FROM PEOPLE
WANTING TO. COME WANTING TO
CONNECT WE'RE NOT AS FAR ALONG
ON IT AS WE LIKE TO BE BUT PART
OF THAT IS BECAUSE IT DOESN'T
WORK- WITHOUT. WANT TO RESEARCH
A BUNCH OF DATA ACQUISITION
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE DIFFERENT
PARTNERS THE STAKEHOLDERS NOW
THERE'S INTERACTIONS WITH- THE
STATE'S MIDDLE MILE WORK. SO
MORTON YOU KNOW THAT'S PERFECT
FOR A SO LET ME MOVE TO- TO A
COUPLE OF QUESTIONS AND ONE IS
THAT A COMMON QUESTION OF LAST
YEAR FOREIGN THIRTY NINE MILLION
DOLLARS WAS PUT IN THE LIBRARY
INFRASTRUCTURE GRANT PROGRAM
WHICH YOU WENT OVER A MINUTE
AGO. AND INTERESTING Y. E. WHEN
I WAS IN THE ASSEMBLY SIXTEEN OR
EIGHTEEN YEARS AGO THE VOTERS
APPROVED A LIBRARY BOND ACT IT
WAS FOR FIVE HUNDRED MILLION AND
SO HERE WE ARE WHEN WE HAVE ONE
TIME MNEY PUTTING IN THE BUDGET
ONE TIME ALMOST EXACTLY WHAT.
THE VOTERS HAD APPROVED YEARS
AGO AND WE DID IT WITHOUT ANY
INTEREST COSTS THE ONE QUESTION
I HAVE IS THAT. OF THE PROJECT
STARTS IN THE BUDGET YEAR BUT A
PROJECTS SUBJECT TO THIS WAS
AVAILABLE FOR ENCUMBRANCE UNTIL
THE END OF THE FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR DOES THAT
MEAN THAT THESE FUNDS ARE FULLY
SUBSCRIBED AND IT'S JUST A
MATTER OF MAKING SURE THEY'RE
DONE BY JUNE OF TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR IS ALL THIS MONEY OUT THE
DOOR. IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING
THAT- THE MONEY CAN BE PUT OUT
THE DOOR OVER A FOUR YEAR PERIOD
AND THE INTENT WAS IT IN OUR
EXPERIENCE- AT AT THE LIBRARY.
YOU KNOW OFTEN THE PEOPLE THAT
WOULD BENEFIT MOST FROM THE
GRANT PROGRAM ARE THE ONES WHO
ARE LEAST PREPARED OR HAVE THE
LEAST RESOURCES. YOU KNOW PUT
TOGETHER AN APPLICATION AND SO
THE THINKING WAS THAT IF WE HAD
THIS MONEY TO BE ABLE TO GIVE IT
OUT OVER OVER A TIME PERIOD THAT
WE BE ABLE TO CATCH AND HELP
MORE MORE OF THAT CATEGORY OF
LIBRARY OR AT. NO I. DON'T THINK
WHAT I WAS JUST TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND. WHAT I WAS TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND IS I THINK THE
IMPLICATION WAS IS THAT THE
PROJECTS NEEDED TO BE SHOVEL
READY SO THAT THEY CAN NOW. THEY
DON'T THEY DON'T NEED TO BE
OBLIGATED THIS YEAR AND DON BY
JUNE TWENTY TWENTY YEAH I THINK
THE FOUR YEAR TIME FRAME IS FOR
US TO GET THE MONEY OUT. OKAY
AND THAT IS WHAT I WAS THE-
PROJECT. SORRY NO THAT'S OKAY
THE- PHONE THAT WAS THE ONE
THING WAS ON CLEAR AND THEN LET
ME. JUST TAKE KNOWLEDGE THAT- WE
- HAD AN- ON THE LGBTQ ARCHIVES
AND YOU ALREADY GOT ALL THOSE
GRANTS OUT THAT. GOOD WORK AND
APPRECIATED. AND IN GETTING. OUR
R. ON BOTH THE THINGS I'VE ASKED
ABOUT I'VE GOTTEN LOTS OF
FEEDBACK THE ANA. THE INDIVIDUAL
LIBRARIES WERE VERY GRATEFUL FOR
THE- BY THE GRANT PROGRAM FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE HIM TO BROADBAND
TO AMAZON MOVED TO MY DISTRICT
DURING RECESS I HEARD ABOUT IT
FROM DIFFERENT LIBRARY SO THAT'S
A VERY. A GOOD THING LET ME ASK
CENTER- CHAU BOGO IF YOU HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS ON THE SIDE. THANK
YOU IT I GUESS I'LL START WITH
THE COMMON AND THEN IT'S A
FOLLOW UP WITH THE QUESTION SO I
READ HERE IN THE ANALYSIS THAT-
THE BUDGET SPECIFIES THE STATE
LIBRARY SURE REQUIRE A LOCAL
MATCH. AND I'M JUST KIND OF
CURIOUS BECAUSE I'M I'M THINKING
OF MY- AREAS SUCH AS MY CITY
WHICH IS I WAS VERY DIFFICULT TO
PASS ANY BONDS- FOR
CONSTRUCTION- IT JUST IN GENERAL
IN IN OUR AREA EVEN WITH THE
SENATOR'S ENDORSEMENT. THIS IS
PRIOR TO THAT I DON'T KNOW ABOUT
NOW I'M GLAD TO CLARIFY YEAH-
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION BUT
MY QUESTION IS- HAVE YOU HAD ANY
FEEDBACK OR ANY COMMENTARY FROM
OUR LIBRARIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE AND HOW DIFFICULT IT WOULD
BE FOR THEM TO HAVE THOSE
MATCHING FUNDS AVAILABLE. OR BE
PREPARED TO. IN ORDER TO HAVE
ACCESS TO THESE CRAMPS. THE
SHORT THE SHORT ANSWER IS YES SO
THE BUDGET THE BUDGET BILL
CONTEMPLATES A DOLLAR FOR DOLLAR
MATCH. BUT KIND OF A FEW
PARAGRAPHS DOWN FROM THAT IT
ALSO DISCUSSES THE ABILITY.
BASED ON. IT'S A FORMULA THAT
CALCULATES KIND OF THE PER
CAPITA NOT KIND OF IT'S A
FORMULA THAT CALCULATES THE-
CAPITA SPENDING IN A
JURISDICTION FOR LIBRARIES. AND
SO THE LOWER THE PER CAPITA
SPENDING IS IN A JURISDICTION.
THE MORE THE LIBRARY CAN REDUCE
THE MATCH THAT'S REQUIRED SO
THERE IS THERE IS A PROVISION IN
THERE THERE'S I THINK THERE'S
THREE DIFFERENT LEVELS. OF THE
PER CAPITA SPENDING SO WE HAVE
THE FLEXIBILITY- THANKS TO THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR TO
BE ABLE TO MODIFY THAT MATCH
REQUIREMENT BASED ON YOU KNOW
HOW WELL HOW WELL RESOURCE. THE
APPLICANTS. OKAY AND- SO JUST SO
THAT I CAN UNDERSTAND. WHAT SORT
OF MATCH WHAT WOULD BE THE LEAST
AMOUNT OF MATCHING FUNDS THAT
WOULD BE REQUIRED BY THE LOCAL
LIBRARIES IN ORDER TO HAVE
ACCESS TO THE FUNDING THAT YOU
HAVE. YEAH YOU KNOW I CAN TELL
YOU WITH PRECISION LATERAYE AYE
AYE FRANKLY FORGOT MY
RECOLLECTION IS THAT SOMETHING
BUT IT'S BETWEEN 25% AND 30% ON
THEIR PART AND SO IN ORDER TO
HAVE SO AND I'M NOT
UNDERSTANDING THE- LOCAL MEANS
OF. HAVANESE FIVE I'M ASSUMING
THESE HAVE TO BE THROUGH LOCAL
BONDS IN ORDER TO HAVE ACCESS TO
FOR THE FOR THE LOCAL I.
RECEIVED GABLE TO HAVE THESE
MONIES FOR THE GRANT. OR ARE
THERE OTHER MEANS OF LOCAL-
LIBRARIES TO HAVE ACCESS TO
FUNDS BESIDES UPON IN ORDER TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THESE GRANTS YEAH
IT'S COMPLETE ONE OF THE COOL
THINGS ABOUT THIS IS IT'S
FLEXIBILITY SENATOR IT DOESN'T-
IT DOESN'T ROB ROY. THE LOCAL
MATCH CAN COME FROM ANY NUMBER
OF DIFFERENT SOURCES WHATEVER
MAKES IT WORK IT JUST CAN'T BE
IN CON RIGHT. SO IT HAS TO BE
SOME KIND OF A- YOU KNOW. MONEY
IN OUR MONETARY SORT OF MATCH.
THANK YOU FOR THE SOURCE OF THAT
MONEY IS WHERE IT'S WERE
COMPLETELY AGNOSTIC ON THAT.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF
COURSE. Q. AND- THAT COMPLETES
ISSUE NUMBER SIX AND COMPLETES
OUR OVERVIEW OF THE STATE
LIBRARY SO- LET ME THANK
EVERYBODY ON THE PANELS WE'RE
HERE FOR THESE ITEMS WE
APPRECIATED AND WE WILL HOLD ALL
THESE ITEMS OPEN AND RETURN TO
THEM IN MAY AFTER THE MAY
REVISE. A WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO
ISSUE NUMBER SEVEN WHICH IS THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA CLIMATE
PROPOSALS- WE HAVE
REPRESENTATIVES OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE AT
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA SO
LET'S BEGIN WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. THE MORNING JACK'S
WALTERNATE FINANCE. THIS
ADMINISTRATION IS COMMITTED TO
ADVANCING SOLUTIONS TO CLIMATE
CHANGE. THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
SEEKS TO LEVERAGE THE EXPERTISE
OF THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
SYSTEM TO FURTHER THOSE EFFORTS.
THESEINVESTMENTS INCLUDE ONE
HUNDRED DOLLARS AND A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND TO SUPPORT RESEARCH AND
EDUCATION WORK- NOTABLY
TRANSLATIONAL RESEARCH GRANTS
DOUBLES AS TECHNOLOGY TRANSFER
FROM THE ACADEMIC REALM- INTO
THE PRACTICAL. FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS ONE TIME GENERAL UND TO
SUPPORT CLIMATE TECHNOLOGY
INCUBATORS ON CAMPUSES- WHICH
COMPLEMENTS OTHER INNOVATION LAB
ACTIVITIES- IN ADDITION PUBLIC
ASSISTANCE IF YOU SEE. AND
THIRTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS ONE
TIME GENERAL FUND FOR CLIMATE
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AT THE
UNIVERSITY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WILL MOVE TO THE HELLO. THERE'S AND CONCENTRATE
SOLELY- ARE YOU PROPOSALS HERE
THAT HAVE AN OVERARCHING-
OBJECTIVE OF HELPING THE STATE
ADDRESS CLIMATE CHANGE ISSUES
WHICH IS A OVER ARCHING
REASONABLE OBJECTIVE- BUT
THERE'S A LOT OF INFORMATION
LACKING IN THESE PROPOSALS ARE.
BUDGET LANGUAGE AND THE LANGUAGE
DOESN'T SET FORTH OBJECTIVES FOR
THE FUNDS IT DOES NOT SET FORTH
CLEAR PARAMETERS OVER HOW THE
FUNDS ARE TO BE USED AS AN
ESTABLISH ANY SORT OF RETRACTED
REPORTING TO ASSIST WITH
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT. WHEN THE
LEGISLATURE RECEIVED PROPOSALS
LIKE THIS IT OFTEN FACES
PRESSURE TO TRY TO CORRECT FOR
SOME OF THESE DEFICIENCIES AND
THAT TAKES TIME AWAY FROM
LEGISLATIVE EFFORTS TO CRAFTED
ITS OWN BUDGET PACKAGE. SO GIVEN
THOSE ISSUES WE THINK THE
LEGISLATURE CURRENT- TREAT THIS
PACKAGE- AND THEN PRIORITIZE
CERTAIN ELEMENTS OF THIS PACKAGE
DIFFERENTLY PRIORITIZING SOME
MORE THAN OTHERS. WE THINK THE
HIGHEST PRIORITY AREA HERE COULD
BE CLIMATE CHANGE RESEARCH.
SUPPORTING MORE CLIMATE CHANGE
RESEARCH COULD HELP THE STATE
ADVANCE- IT'S CLIMATE MITIGATION
GOALS. AND HELP WITH- COORDINATE
LOCAL LAPTOP- ADAPTATION EFFORTS. BERMAN IS ALSO REASONABLE USE
OF ONE TIME FUNDING. THAT'S SORT
OF THE LEGISLATURE IS INTERESTED
IN PURSUING MORE RESEARCH WE
THINK THERE ARE- SEVERAL CHANGES
A LEGISLATURE COULD MAKE TO THE
PROPOSAL- TWO KEY AREAS WITHIN
THE LEGISLATURE COULD FOCUS ON
IS ENSURING. A MORE COORDINATION
BETWEEN YOU SEE IN THE STATE'S
VARIOUS ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION
AND NATURAL RESOURCE AGENCIES.
AND WE ALSO RECOMMENDED JUST
MORE STATUTORY GUIDANCE OVER THE
GOALS OF THE FUNDS THAT SETTING
THE PARAMETERS ARE HOW THE FUNDS
TO BE USED AND ESTABLISHING
REPORTING LANGUAGE. WITH REGARD
TO THE PROPOSED CLIMATE
TECHNOLOGY INCUBATORS WE THINK
THAT COULD BE TREATED AS A LOWER
PRIORITY RELATIVE TO RESEARCH.
REPORTING MORE CLIMATE
TECHNOLOGY INCUBATORS COULD HAVE
SOME OF THE SAME BENEFITS AS
SUPPORTING MORE RESEARCH TO THE
EXTENT THA IT. FOSTERS THE
FORMATION OF NEW INDUSTRIES THAT
CREATE NEW TECHNOLOGIES THAT
HELP ADDRESS CLIMATE CHANGE
ISSUES. THAT'S WHAT THE STATE
HAS MANY NUMEROUS- ECONOMIC
INNOVATION INITIATIVES AS MANY
EXISTING INCUBATORS INCLUDING A
FEW REGULATORS A FOCUS ON
CLIMATE ISSUES. THERE'S ALSO
JUST A LOT OF BASIC INFORMATION
LACKING IN THIS PROPOSAL FOR
EXAMPLE THE LEGISLATURE DOESN'T
KNOW THE LOCATION OF THE
PROPOSED INCUBATORS OTHER SCOPE
. THIS IS AN AREA WHERE WE THINK
OF THE LEGISLATURE WERE
INTERESTED IN SUPPORTING THIS
PROPOSAL. IT WE THINK IT COULD
DIRECT THE ADMINISTRATION AND
UNIVERSITY TO COME BACK WITH A
MORE DETAILED PROPOSAL. FINALLY
REGARDING THE WORK FORCE ALMOND
OF THIS PROPOSAL- WE THINK YOU
COULD TREAT THIS AS THE LOWEST
PRIORITY AT THE STATE IS ALREADY
FUNDING MANY ONGOING WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS. AND ALSO
FUNDED MANY ONE TIME WORKFORCE
INITIATIVES IN LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET. INCLUDING SOME THAT
APPEAR TO SHARE SOME
SIMILARITIES TO- THE UC PROPOSAL
. FOR THIS REASON WE THINK YOU
COULD REJECT THIS PROPOSAL
WITHOUT TRYING TO PROVIDE. MUCH
MORE INFORMATION ON IT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MOVED TO THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA. GOOD
MORNING CENTER LAYERED AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU FOR HAVING ME HERE TODAY I'M
SAY EVER KIND OF REPRESENTING
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA.
I'M A CRISIS IS IMPACTING THE
LIVES OF ALL CALIFORNIANS WHILE
THE STATE LEADERSHIP HAVE TAKEN
SIGNIFICANT STEPS TOWARD
MITIGATION OF CLIMATE CHANGE. IT
IS CLEAR THAT MORE NEEDS TO BE
DONE TO BOTH MITIGATE AND ADAPT.
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL COMMITS
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA'S
RESOURCES EXPERTISE
INFRASTRUCTURE NETWORKS AND
PARTNERSHIPS. TO ADDRESS THE
STATE'S NEEDS AND ACCELERATE THE
STATE'S PROGRESS TOWARDS CLIMATE
RESILIENCY GOALS. THE PURPOSE OF
THE THREE PROGRAMS IS TO
GENERATE IDEAS PRODUCTS AND
SERVICES AS WELL AS A TRAINED
WORK FORCE. TO HELP CALIFORNIANS
BECOME MORE RESILIENT TO THE
CHANGING CLIMATE. THE GOVERNOR
PROPOSES AN AMBITIOUS PLAN FOR
INNOVATIVE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA RESEARCH ON CLIMATE
ADAPTATION STRATEGIES. THE
PROPOSED ONE HUNDRED MILLION FOR
RESEARCH WOULD BE PROVIDED FOR
CUTTING EDGE TRANSLATIONAL
SCIENCE. THESE GRANTS WILL BE
UNIQUE AND FUNDING INNOVATIVE
CONCEPT WORK NOT FUNDED THROUGH-OTHER STATE AGENCIES ARE THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. THE
OBJECTIVE WILL BE TO SEEK NEW
KNOWLEDGE THAT HAS NOT YET BEEN
PREVIOUSLY EXPLORED. REGIONAL
INNOVATION INCUBATORS WILL BE
AWARDED BASED ON CONSIDERATIONS
OF EQUITY REGIONAL CONTEXT LOCAL
TRIBAL AND COMMUNITY
PARTNERSHIPS AS WELL AS ABILITY
TO LEVERAGE OUTSIDE INVESTMENTS
AND RESOURCES. INNOVATION
INVESTMENTS ARE CONCEIVED TO
COVER A RANGE OF FIELDS AND
ACTIITIES SPENDING AGRICULTURE
AND HEALTH TRAINING WHAT BLOOD
THE MAKER SPACE ACTIVITIES MULTI
DISCIPLINARY NETWORKS OF
INCUBATION AND LAB FACILITIES.
COMBINED INCUBATOR ACCELERATOR
AND CO WORKING SPACES THEY WILL
BE OPEN TO INNOVATORS INSIDE AND
OUTSIDE OF THE UNIVERSITY EAST
WITH BROAD PARTICIPATION AND
ENGAGEMENT FROM INDUSTRY AND THE
PUBLIC SECTOR. REGIONAL CLIMATE
WORKFORCE HUBS ARE INTENDED
PRIMARILY THE SERVER
UNDERGRADUATE AND GRADUATE
STUDENTS FROM ACROSS THE STATE
PUBLIC HIGHER EDUCATION SEGMENTS
AS WELL AS ALUMNI WHO CAN
PARTICIPATE IN ALL THE JOB
TRAINING FOR HUB FUNDED
ACTIVITIES. YOUR CERTIFICATION
TRAINING THROUGH PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT B. R. U. C.
EXTENSION AND ON THE JOB
TRAINING AT THE INNOVATION HUBS
WILL PROVIDE THE TOOLS RESOURCES
AND SUPPORT THE PREPARE
CANDIDATES FOR A RANGE OF
COMMUNITY RESILIENCE CAREER
OPPORTUNITIES. INCLUDING FOR NON
DEGREE SEEKINGINDIVIDUALS. THE
OVERALL OBJECTIVES OF THE
UNIVERSITY'S CLIMATE RESILIENCY
FUNDING ARE TO CONTRIBUTE TO A
HEALTHY ENVIRONMENT A VIBRANT
ECONOMY AND A JUST AND EQUITABLE
COMMUNITIES WE ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED HUNDRED EIGHTY FIVE
MILLION FOR CLIMATE RESILIENCY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND- I'M I
DON'T THINK CENTER GROW TROUBLED
HAS ANY QUESTIONS IS THAT
CORRECT. THEN INSTEAD OF ASKING
QUESTIONS I'M GOING TO MAKE A
COMMENT AID THAT IS AS SOMEBODY
WHO WAS US SECRETARY FOR NATURAL
RESOURCES AND IT WAS MENTIONED-
ALIGNING WITH THE AGENCIES IN-
THE ELIAS'S COMMENTS I WOULD
HAVE DIED FOR THIS APPLICATION
THIS. IS THROWING IN OUR A AND I
SUPPORT. A THIS. ONE ARM ON
CLEAR ON IS I AGREE. ARE WITH
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
COMMENT ABOUT THE LACK OF
DIRECTION OR LACK OF
COORDINATION WITH THE AGENCIES
IN. ARE THE IMPORTANT THING IS
THE STATE'S POLICY. ALL SEIZE ON
CLIMATE ARE BASED ON SCIENCE THE
QUESTION IS DO WHAT WE NEED AT
THE AGENCIES ALIGNED WITH THE
RESEARCHER AND FREQUENTLY I SAW
THIS IN THE OCEAN SCIENCE TRUST
WHICH IS. OCEAN RESEARCHERS FROM
ACROSS THE STATE THE DID
RESEARCH IN RELATION TO THE
STATE THAT MANY TIMES THEY DID
RESEARCH ABOUT WHAT THEY THOUGHT
THEIR OWN NEEDS WORK. R. FOR
RESEARCH NOT WHAT ALIGNED WITH
THE STATE PROGRAMS ON OCEAN AND
I THINK THERE'S THE POTENTIAL
FOR THAT HAPPENING HERE. AND WE
STILL. ARE NEED OUR OUR WAY TO
QUANTIFY- GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS SAVINGS FROM PROGRAMS
THAT AFFECT NATURAL AND WORKING
LANDS WE STILL NEED TO KNOW SOME
OF THE SCIENCE OF OCEANS AS TO
WHETHER OR NOT CERTAIN THINGS.
CAN DEAL WITH OCEAN
ACIDIFICATION AND SO THE
QUESTION IS CAN WE USE THIS
UNIQUE OPPORTUNITY. AND UC'S
UNIQUE ABILITIES ON RESEARCH TO
ALIGN WITH THE RESEARCH NEEDS
FOR STATE AGENCIES AND THE STATE
CLIMATE PROGRAM AND I THINK THAT
POINT WAS MADE BY THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST AND I THINK
IT'S EXACTLY RIGHT SO. WHAT WHAT
I WOULD HOPE IS I THINK THE THAT
IF YOU LISTEN TO THE STATEMENTS
PARTICULARLY THE REPRESENTATIVE
OF THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
THE BULK OF THE STATEMENT WAS
ABOUT CLIMATE AND HOW IT'S
CHANGING AND THE NEED TO
ADDRESS. BUT I THINK THE DUMB
PORTANT THING IS HOW IS THIS
RESEARCH AND HOWARD THESE
ACTIVITIES GOING TO BE FOCUSED
IN RELATION TO WHAT WE HAVE TO
DO. AND WE JUST HAVE SO MANY
THINGS AND THEN THE STATE HAS
FACILITATED. ARE AT LEAST FOUR
DIFFERENT SCIENTIFIC ASSESSMENT.
ARE AND I THINK THE LAST ONE THE
FOURTH ASSESSMENT HAS BEEN OUT
FOR THREE OR FOUR YEARS ALREADY.
AND IT REALLY LOOKED AT THE
STATE AND IT LOOKED AT. OUR GRID
WHAT WE HAVE TO DO TO PROTECT
OUR GRID GIVEN HEAT AND WILDFIRE
IT LOOKED AT SOME OF THE OCEANS
ISSUES. THEY LOOKED AT WILDLIFE
QUARTERS THE FACT THAT THE
CLIMATES ARE CHANGING AND A
WILDLIFE WILL HAVE TO MOVE IN
WAYS THAT THEY HAVEN'T BEFORE.
AND I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THAT
THIS RESEARCH IS FOCUSED AND I
THINK THUS FAR. IT'S A GENERAL
PROPOSAL SO I HOPE THAT. THAT
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA AND
THE STATE GENCIES WILL WORK
BETWEEN NOW AND MAY TO FOCUS
THIS SO THAT WHEN IT COMES BACK
TO US. WE HAVE CLARITY ON THESE
ISSUES EARLY BECAUSE THAT WOULD
BE THE BASIS ON WHICH TO APPROVE
THIS AND MOVE THIS FORWARD IN
MAY AND JUNE IN THE FINAL BUDGET
AND AS I SAID I SUPPORT THIS. I
WANT TO MAKE SURE. THAT IT'S
FOCUSED IN A CLEAR WAY AND SO
THAT IS JUST A COMMENT AND I
THINK. SORT OF A DIRECTION TO
THE STAKEHOLDERS. BEFORE THIS
COMES BACK. IN AFTER THE MEASURE
. ANY FURTHER. OR COMMENTS. THEN
THANK YOU WE REALLY ARE-
APPRECIATE- YOU BEING HERE AND
WE ARE GOING TO MOVE. TWO ISSUE
NUMBER EIGHT WHICH IS THE FOSTER
YOUTH PROPOSALS AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA AND
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY AND
WE HAVE- JACK'S WALLED AGAIN
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
JENNIFER LOUIS FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WITH THE
KING FROM THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE SAY HOW VIRGIN
AND AGAIN FROM THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA. AND ROEMER RIO FROM
THE CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
AND WILL TAKE THE PANEL IN THAT
ORDER- SO DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
WELCOME BACK TO THE- TO THE
COMMITTEE. I THINK THE SAGAMORE
JACKSON'S FORMER FINANCE-
MICHAEL GENERALLY WILL BE
HANDLING THE PRESENTATION THIS
PARTICULAR ITEM. THANK YOU. YEAH
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET I THINK
THE SUPPORT POSSIBLE FORMER
PROSECUTOR WE'RE SORT OF HAVING
TROUBLE HEARING YOU I DON'T KNOW
IF THERE'S SOMETHING ON YOUR END
OR ARE AND MIGHT OKAY SORRY MY%
THANK YOU PARDON ME- THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROVIDES AN
INCREASE SUPPORT FOR FOSTER
YOUTH AND FORMER FOSTER YOUTH
ATTENDING THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY WITH ONGOING
GENERAL FUND INVESTMENTS OF SIX
MILLION AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA. AND TWELVE MILLION
AT THE CALIFORNIA STATE. BUT
THAT I. SHALL COME MY PRE. AND I
AM AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH THEN
WE'RE GONNA GO ON TO A LISA CAME
FROM THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE. R. SHE NEEDS TO BE ON
MUTE- JASON'S ON MUTED OKAY. I
JUST RECEIVED A MESSAGE FROM MY
COLLEAGUE THAT SHE'S
EXPERIENCING SOME TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTIES- I DON'T THINK WE
HAD A WHOLE LOT OF COMMON TO
OFFER ON ON THIS ITEM- SO IT BUT
I'D BE HAPPY TO AND- BROWN
ANSWERING QUESTIONS. OKAY AND
THEN WILL MOVE TO THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA SAID. THANK YOU
RECOGNIZING TO UNIQUE OBSTACLES
FACED BY FORMER FOSTER YOUTH THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL INCLUDES SIX
MILLION AN ONGOING FUNDS FOR
STUDENT SERVICES AND ACADEMIC
ADVISING. SPECIFICALLY DIRECTED
A FORMER FOSTER YOUTH. THIS
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT WILL ASSIST
THEM ON THE PATH TO SUCCESSFUL
GRADUATION. THESE STUDENTS HAVE
ALREADY OVERCOME TREMENDOUS
OBSTACLES IN PURSUING THEIR
EDUCATIONAL GOALS BUT STILL FACE
UNIQUE AND SIGNIFICANT
CHALLENGES AS THEY MAKE PROGRESS
TOWARDS GRADUATION. FORMER
FOSTER YOUTH ARE TWO AND A HALF
MORE TIMES LIKELY TO EXPERIENCE
HOMELESSNESS THAN OTHER
STUDENTS. AND FAR MORE LIKELY TO
REPORT FOOD INSECURITY
ADDITIONAL ACADEMIC ADVISING AND
SUPPORT SERVICES WOULD HELP THE
STUDENTS GET ACCESS TO RESOURCES
THEY NEED TO GRADUATE AND
THRIVE. WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
FOR THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED SIX
MILLION. THREE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WILL MOVE ON TO MR MURRAY-
FROM THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY. A GOOD MORNING AND
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR TO RAISE TO DISCUSS THIS
YEAR'S YOU PROSECUTE PROGRAMS
IN- OUR CAMPUSES. WILL PROVIDE A
GENERAL OVERVIEW OF OUR PROGRAMS
IN THE SYSTEM WILL START WITH
THE NUMBER OF PROGRAMS THAT WE
ARE ACTUALLY CURRENTLY EXIST.
THE TWENTY ONE OF TWENTY THREE
CAMPUSES CURRENTLY HAVE A FORMER
AND CURRENT BUST YOU PROGRAM. IN
ONE IS ACTUALLY UNDER
DEVELOPMENT. SO BY THE END OF
THIS ACADEMIC YEAR WILL SOON
HAVE TWENTY TWO OVER TWENTY
THREE CAMPUSES WITH THE PROGRAM.
IN REGARDS TO ENROLLMENT THE CSU
HAS JUST OVER TWENTY SEVEN
HUNDRED KERN IN FORMER FOSTER
YOUTH THAT HAVE SELF IDENTIFIED
IN AND ROLLED ON OUR VARIOUS
CAMPUSES. THE ACTUAL NUMBER IS
PROBABLY LIKELY TO BE A LITTLE
BIT LARGER SINCE THERE'S NO
OBLIGATION FOR A FORMER OR
CURRENT BUST YOU. THE SELF
IDENTIFY OVER DISCLOSES THEY HAD
BEEN IN THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM.
BUT WITHIN THE TWENTY SEVEN
HUNDRED STUDENTS THAT WE HAVE IN
THE SYSTEM OVER THIRTEEN HUNDRED
STUDENTS ARE SPECIFICALLY BEING
SERVED BY A FORMER FOSTER YOUTH
PROGRAM. NO THAT'S NOT TO
SUGGEST THAT THE REMAINING
STUDENTS ARE NOT BEING SERVED
THE STUDENTS ARE TYPICALLY
SERVED BY OUR EDUCATIONAL
OPPORTUNITY PROGRAM. THAT
PROVIDES A SAFETY NET FOR THE
STUDENTS. TO ENSURE THEIR
ACADEMIC SUCCESS. IN REGARDS TO
FUNDING THE CAMPS OF EURO TO
COME. OF STATE EXT FUNDING TO
SUPPORT THEIR PROGRAMS. THE
STATE FUNDING IS A COMBINATION
OF THE CAMPUS GENERAL FUNDS BUT
ALSO A VAST MAJORITY OF THEM
ALSO UTILIZE FUNDING FROM THE
EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITY PROGRAM
TO SUPPORT THEIR EFFORTS. BUT
IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT TO KNOW THAT
THE EXTERNAL FUNDING THROUGH
GRANTS AND FUNDRAISING. REALLY
ADDS UP TO ABOUT 60% OF THE
OPERATIONAL AND PROGRAM SUPPORT
OF OUR PROGRAMS. YOU KNOW MONEY
WERE PROGRAMS DO YOU HAVE STRONG
INDICATORS OF SUCCESS MANY THE
PROGRAMS ARE SHOWING THAT THERE
HAVE UP TO NINETY FOUR PERCENT.
OF PERSISTENCE RATES AFTER THE
FIRST YEAR IN AS HIGH AS EIGHTY
THREE PERCENT. OF PERSISTENCE
RATES AFTER THE SECOND YEAR OF
ENROLLMENT. NOW THE GRADUATION
RATES FOR FORMER FOSTER YOUTH IN
NATIONALLY AND THOSE WHO PURSUE
COLLEGE IS ONLY ABOUT ONE TO
FIVE PERCENT. HOWEVER OUR FUSTY
PROGRAMS ON OUR CAMPUSES ARE
EXPERIENCING UP TO A 60%
GRADUATION RATE I REQUEST YOU
THAT THEY'RE SERVING. IN THE
OTHER INDICATOR THAT WE LOOK AT
ALSO IS THE ACADEMIC STANDING IN
MOST OF THE PROGRAMS ARE WORKING
WITH STUDENTS AT OUR REMAINING
90% RATE IN- KIDS ACADEMIC
STANDING. ELEANOR TO ENSURE THE
SUCCESS VERY SUPPORT SERVICES
THAT WE PROVIDE OF COURSE OUR
PROGRAM STAFFING. NOW AS YOU
NOTICE FROM THE INITIAL NUMBERS
WE DO HAVE. LIMITATIONS ON
CAPACITY MOST OF THE PROGRAMS
ARE STAFFED BY ONE THE TWO STAFF
MEMBERS AND MOST OF THIS MANY OF
THE STAFF MEMBERS. ACTUALLY
FUNDED THROUGH GRANTS SUPPORT
NOT PERMANENT FUNDING. THE BILL
WITH ADDITIONAL STAFFING
STABILITY IN FUNDING WE
CERTAINLY CAN INCREASE THE
CAPACITY OF OUR PROGRAMS. HERE
THE IMPORTANT IMPORTANT ASPECT
OF OUR PROGRAMS IS ACTUALLY
CASELOAD MANAGEMENT IN THIS IS
TO ENSURE THAT THE FOSTER YOUTH
PROGRAMS ARE FIRST YEAR
STUDENTS. ARE CLOSELY MONITORED
TO ENSURE THEIR ACADEMIC SUCCESS
BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY THEY'RE
SEEKING THE SERVICES OUTSIDE OF
THE CLASSROOM TO ENSURE THAT
ACADEMIC SUCCESS AND OUR
PERSISTENCE ON CAMPUSES. HOUSING
IS ANOTHER CRITICAL AREA THAT
ARE SORRY IF YOU COULD BEGIN TO
WRAP UP. SURE SURE IN THE OTHER
CRITICAL SERVICES IS THE MENTAL
HEALTH SUPPORT ACCESS TO
TECHNOLOGY HERE A. PROGRAM
BECAUSE WELL. THE WEATHER
FUNDING TO HELP. AND ENHANCE
FOSTER PROGRAMS OUT THREE
CAMPUSES AND DEVELOP SUPPORT
SUPPORTIVE CAMPUS COMMUNITY IS
CERTAINLY WELCOME I DO NEED TO
POINT OUT THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL IS AN ADD ON BUDGET
ITEM AND NOT PART OF THE CSU
TRUSTEES BUDGET REQUEST. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. AND LET BE A ARE
THERE ANY QUESTIONS ON THIS ONE.
SENATOR TROUBLED SHE HAS NO
QUESTIONS AND- I WAS JUST GONNA
KNOWLEDGE THAT- THAT WE HEARD
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE FOSTER.
CARE ITEM UNDER COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AND I DON'T HAVE A
BILL. THAT'S WORKING ON THAT
THIS THIS JUST SEEMS FINE AND I
DON'T I THINK THE REASON WE
DON'T HAVE ANY QUESTIONS AS
WE'RE GENERALLY SUPPORT SO. LET
ME THANK EVERYBODY FOR- OF BEING
HERE. AND PRESENTED TODAY. ARE
WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO- ISSUE
NINE WHICH IS THE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY SYSTEM CLIMATE
PROPOSALS. ARE WE HAVE JENNIFER
LOWERY FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE WE SICKENING- FOR JASON
FROM THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE AND BY SAN JUAN FROM THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY LOGO
IN THAT ORDER BEGIN WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. BUT AGAIN
JENNIFER LEE WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. CLOSE THE FOLLOWING
ONE TIME INVESTMENTS AT THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY TO
SUPPORT CLIMATE CHANGE
INNOVATION WHICH IS EIGHTY THREE
MILLION A ONE TIME GENERAL FUND
TO SUPPORT THE CONSTRUCTIONOF
THE CSU BAKERSFIELD ENERGY
INNOVATION CENTER AND FIFTEEN
MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL FUND
FOR EQUIPMENT AND INFRASTRUCTURE
IMPROVEMENTS AT CSU UNIVERSITY
FARMS WITH THAT I. SHALL
CONCLUDE MY PRISON. PRESENTATION
AND AN ADMIRABLE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL MOVE TO
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S. GOOD
MORNING TRANSCEND OKAY BE
THINKING AND LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE. THE CONCEALED
AN EXAMINATION CENTRE AND THE
UNIVERSITY PARK SCHOOL SELECTION
HERNANDEZ BEGINNING ON PAGE
THIRTY. REGARDING PROPOSED BE
REYES CAN. WE DON'T THINK THESE
FROM HAVE AND NOTABLE KIND OF.
REGARDING THE BAKERSFIELD ENERGY
INNOVATION CNTER THIS PROPOSAL
HAS BEEN PRESENTED TO SUPPORTING
KIND SEARCH BASED ON PROJECT
DATA PROVIDED BY CSU ONLY A
SMALL PORTION ROUGHLY 10% OF THE
SPACE IS DEDICATED TO RESEARCH.
THE SPACE TO THE LEFT TURN
ACCESS TO CLIMATE CHANGE ISSUES
FOR EXAMPLE INCLUDES TEACHING
LABS TO SUPPORT B. ENGINEERING
PHYSICS AND COMPUTER SCIENCE
DEPARTMENT. REGARDING UNIVERSITY
FARMS HELLO THE REQUESTED FROM
CSU LESTER THE SPECIFIC PROJECTS
THAT CAMPUS IS LIKE THE PERSON
WITH THE PROPOSED FIFTY MILLION
. SOME OF THESE PROJECTS TO HELP
CLIMATE RELATED BENEFITS FOR
EXAMPLE A PROJECT TO REPLACE
OLDER FARM VEHICLES WITH
ELECTRIC VEHICLES. OTHER
PROJECTS HARPER THE KIND OF
RELATED BENEFITS ARE MUCH LESS
CARE FOR EXAMPLE A PROJECT PLAN
ASKED FACE TWENTY. THIS ISSUE
THE REASON IS PROPOSE IS THAT
OUR VIEW DON'T REFLECT THE
HIGHER PRIOR CAPITAL PER. YES
YOU. FOR TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE
SO HE WAS THIS WITH LEICESTER
THREE OUT PRIOR. NO THOSE
PRIORITIES ARE TO THE IN. FOR IN
ADDITION CENTER IS YES HE
PRIORITY LIST. HOW PROJECTS
ABOUT THAT IN AN THIS WITHOUT
THAT THE- LIKE CVS INCLUDING
SIZE OF DEFICIENCY IS. AS WELL
AS THE CONTINUATION OF EXISTING
CAMPUS OPERATIONS. OVER THINK
IT'S REASONABLE TO PRIORITIZE
THESE TYPES OF PRODUCTS. WITH
THIS IN MIND WE RECOMMEND
LEGISLATURE CONSIDER THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSALS IN THIS
ISSUE HERE AS A LOWER SPENDING
PRIORITY. IT COULD CONSIDER
REDIRECTING THESE FUNDS TOWARD
pTHAT BE A HIGHER PRIORITY
CAPITAL PROJECTS IF YOU. OR
POTENTIALLY PROJECTS IN OTHER
DEPARTMENTS THAT HAVE A CLEAR
ACCESS TO CLIMATE CHANGE
RESEARCH AND DEVELOPMENT. WE
WOULD KNOW THE BOTH OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSALS THIS ISSUE
ARE EXCLUDABLE FROM THE STATE
APPROPRIATIONS LIMIT. INTERNAL
CHARITIES OF THE FUNDS VERY
LIKELY GOING TO BE AS LONG. OKAY
THANK YOU FOR MUCH NOW MOVES TO
THE REPRESENTATIVE OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
SYSTEM. I CAN MORNING THANK YOU
TERROR ALERT MY NAME IS FIVE
SEVEN ONE I'M THE ASSISTANT VICE
CHANCELLOR FOR CAPITAL PLANNING.
DESIGN CONSTRUCTION FOR THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY I'M
HERE TO ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR
THE PROJECTS PROPOSED BY THE
GOVERNOR TO HELP CALIFORNIA
PREPARE FOR CLIMATE CHANGE. THE
FIRST PROJECT IS THE CSU
BAKERSFIELD ENERGY AND
ENGINEERING INNOVATION BUILDING
THE PROJECT WAS APPROVED BY THE
BOARD OF TRUSTEES AS PART OF THE
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY TWO. TWENTY
THREE BUDGET REQUEST. THE
PROJECT IS THE HIGHEST PRIORITY
FOR OUR BIGGEST BILL CAMPUS.
WILL ACCOMMODATE THE NEW
ENVIRONMENTAL SCIENCES ACADEMIC
PROGRAM IT'LL PROVIDE SPACE FOR
THE GROWTH OF. YOUR SCIENCES
PHYSICS AND ENGINEERING THE
PROVIDE HANDSON LEARNING SPACE
FOR THE FABRICATION OF STUDENT
PROJECTS MAKERSPACE. THE
UNIVERSITY'S ENVIRONMENTAL
SCIENCES PROGRAM WILL COMPLEMENT
THE WORK OF THE CALIFORNIA
ENERGY RESEARCH CENTER AND
INDUSTRY PARTNERS IN THE
RESEARCH AND STUDY AREAS. OF
CARBON SEQUESTRATION OF CARBON
MANAGEMENT RENEWABLE ENERGY
STORAGE SYSTEMS AND SMART GRID
TECHNOLOGY. HANDS ON LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES IN THE STEM FIELDS
IS A HIGH IMPACT PRACTICE THAT
IMPROVES GRADUATION RATES AND IN
TURN. THE TENCEL FOR UPWARD
MOBILITY OF STUDENTS COMING FROM
ECONOMICALLY CHALLENGED AREAS IN
THE BAKERSFIELD REGION. ARTICLE
BENEFIT STATE IT BY NO ONLY SO
RESEARCH IN CLIMATE CHANGE THAT
WILL SUPPORT THE LEGISLATURE
SCHOOL IMPROVE GRADUATION RATES
DEVELOP STUDENTS READY TO SERVE
THE STATE'S WORKFORCE NEEDS. IN
THE GREEN JOBS INDUSTRY AND
PROMOTE APPLIED RESEARCH IN THE
DEVELOPMENT OF INNOVATIVE
PRODUCTS AND SERVICES. IN
TRANSFORMING THE ENERGY FIELD.
THE SECOND PROJECT WOULD PROVIDE
FIFTY MILLION IN ONE TIME FUNDS
TO SUPPORT AGRICULTURE PROGRAMS
AT CSU FRESNO. CHICO CAL POLY
SAN LUIS OBISPO AND CAL POLY
POMONA. THE CSU AGRICULTURE
PROGRAMS INCLUDE LIVING
LABORATORIES THE FARMS ORCHARDS
LANDS VINEYARDS FOREST AND
ANIMAL UNITS COMING COVERING
THOUSANDS OF ACRES THE ESTIMATED
AGRICULTURAL FACILITY BACKLOG
VERNAL OR DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
TOTALS OVER THREE HUNDRED
MILLION. EACH OF THE FOUR
CAMPUSES HAVE IDENTIFIED OVER
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS IN
PROJECTS TO MODERNIZE FACILITIES
AND REPLACE AGED INFRASTRUCTURE
AND OR EQUIPMENT THESE PROJECTS
HELPED TO ADAPT TO A CHANGING
CLIMATE BY PERFORMING RESEARCH
INCREASING STUDENT ACCESS AND
SUPPORTING WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
SHOULD ONE TIME ADDITIONAL FUNDS
BE AVAILABLE FOR. UNIVERSITY I
RECALL TERM PROJECTS. POST FIFTY
MILLION IN THEGOVERNOR'S BUDGET
WOULD BE EQUALLY DIVIDED BETWEEN
THE FOUR CAMPUSES ARE TWELVE
POINT FIVE MILLION PER CAMPUS A
LIST OF PROJECTS HAS BEEN
PROVIDED TO DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND LEGISLATIVE.
ANALYST'S OFFICE THAT INCLUDE
PROJECTS TO PROMOTE TECHNOLOGY
INCUBATION ENABLE CLIMATE SMART
AGRICULTURE AND VALUE ADDED
PRODUCTION PRACTICES THESE
INCLUDE ENERGY EFFICIENT FARM
EQUIPMENT WATER IRRIGATION
IMPROVEMENTS. IMPROVEMENTS THE
CELLS OBISPO DAIRY PROCESSING
LAB FRESNO FARM VEHICLE UPGRADES
THE MOTIVE BE THERE PERRY.
PROGRAM EXPANSION HELP MITIGATE
THE LOSS OF THESE CRITICAL TO
CROP COLONIZATION AND INCREASE
STUDENT ACCESS AT THE PAUL
MELBOURNE UNIVERSITY PHARMACY AS
YOU TO GO WHICH WAS ESTABLISHED
IN NINETEEN SIXTY THROUGH THE
EFFORTS OF THE NAME STATE
SENATOR PAUL ELLSBERG. THANK YOU
FOR CAN YOUR CONSIDERATION AND
SUPPORT OF THE CSU FACILITIES
THAT WILL PROMOTE EDUCATION
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AND
APPLIED RESEARCH AND- THE.
DEVELOPMENT OF CLIMATE CHANGE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ARMY S. TO
GIVEN EQUAL. SHE HAS NO
QUESTIONS I WOULD. IN A MODIFIED
FORM RENEW MY COMMENTS ABOUT THE
UC CLIMATE REPORT PROPOSALS THAT
WE HADN'T. NOT ARE I NOTED THAT
THERE WAS- IT WAS STATED ABOUT
THE GOALS OF WORK FORCE
GRADUATION RATE- THAT THE CSU
SUPPORTED IN THE BUILDING PLAN
THAT THERE'S A BACKLOG OF AG
MAINTENANCE AND NEED TO UPDATE
THE SYLLABUS. BUT THIS MONEY IS
SPECIFICALLY FOR CLIMATE AND
CLIMATE RESEARCH AND SO WHAT I
WOULD REALLY HOPE IS THAT
BETWEEN NOW AND MAY THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST OUR CONCERNS
ARE DRESSED AND THAT WHEN WE
HAVE A MORE REFINED PROPOSAL IN
FRONT OF US IN THE MAY REVISED.
IT IS REALLY CLEAR HOW EACH PART
ACTUALLY ADDRESSES CLIMATE AND
ACTUALLY ALIGNS WITH THE STATE
AGENCIES WORK MORE BECAUSE I
JUST DON'T THINK THIS IS A- ARE
NOT. TO JAM OTHER THINGS IT THIS
IS REALLY ABOUT CLIMATE AND SO
WHEN THIS COMES BACK TO US. AND
WHEN THE GOVERNOR DOES THE MAY
REVISE WHICH REFINES HIS
PROPOSALS I HOPE THERE'S CLARITY
ON EVERY PIECE OF THIS
APPROPRIATION AND HOW IT ALIGNS
WITH CLIENT THAT'S GOING TO BE
VERY IMPORTANT TO US. I THANK
EVERYBODY ON THIS PANEL. OUR OUR
FOR THEIR PRESENTATION AND FOR
BEING HERE. WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO
ISSUE TEN WHICH IS
IMPLEMENTATION MPLEMENTATION.
OF THE BUDGET ACT AGREEMENTS
WITH REGARD TO THE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY SYSTEM. AND THE
ONE PANELIST WE HAVE IS RUN
STORM FROM CALIFORNIA. STATE
UNIVERSITY SYSTEM ARE WELCOME TO
THE COMMITTEE. I THANK YOU
SENATOR LAYERS- MY NAME IS RYAN
STORM HAS SAID NINE THE SYSTEM
VICE CHANCELLOR FOR BUDGET FOR
THE OFFICE OF THE CHANCELLOR. I
YOUR GENDER CONTAINS SIX ITEMS
AND I WILL VERY BRIEFLY DESCRIBE
EACH AND LET ME KNOW WHERE WE
STAND ON THEM. THE FIRST IS THE
DUAL ADMISSIONS ATHLETE PROGRAM
NOW THIS PROGRAM CREATES A
GUARANTEE THAT A FIRST YEAR
STUDENT WILL BE ADMITTED TO
ISSUE CAMPUS TWO YEARS AS A
TRANSFER STUDENT. IF THAT'S A
STUDENTS SUCCESSFULLY COMPLETING
THE SERVICE YET DEGREE FOR
TRANSFER SIMILAR. SORT OF
PROGRAM. NOW THE PROGRAM IS-
SCHEDULED TO COMMENCE IN THE
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR
ACADEMIC YEAR IN THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE IS DEEPLY
INVOLVED IN SEVERAL PLANNING
STAGES HERE. THAT INCLUDES A
WORKING ON A COMMUNICATIONS PLAN
TO ENSURE THAT HIGH SCHOOL
COUNSELORS ARE AWARE OF THIS
UPCOMING OPPORTUNITY SO STILL
MORE TO COME PROJECT ISN'T
COMPLETED AT THIS POINT. THE
SECOND ON YOUR AGENDA IS THE
HUMBOLDT CAMPUS- TRANSITION TO A
POLITECNICA RECIPE. NOW THIS IS
NEVER REQUIRE SOME SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENTS THE ACADEMIC AND
CAPITAL PROGRAM- NEEDS TO GROW
STEM PROGRAMS BEYOND WHERE THEY
ARE TODAY. YEAH THE CAMPUS
ORIGINALLY PREPARED A
POLYTECHNIC THE PROCESS
PERSPECTIVES LAST FALL IN THE
TRUSTEES RECENTLY CHANGED THE
NAME OF THE CAMPUS CAL POLY
HUMBLE IN JULY. AND JANUARY
SORRY. ALSO ON THE ACADEMIC SIDE
OF THE HOUSE HUMBOLDT IS ON
TRACK- WITH PROPOSED AND NEWLY
ESTABLISHED ECONOMIC PROGRAMMING
FOR THE CAMPUS IS PERSPECTIVES.
ALREADY IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE WE
HAVE A BACHELOR OF SCIENCE
DEGREES APPROVED IN MARINE
BIOLOGY AND DATA SCIENCE. IN THE
NEXT MONTH THE TRUSTEES WILL
CONSIDER APPROVAL POSITIONAL
DEGREES- SOME OF THOSE PROGRAMS
WILL BE. READY TO ADMIT STUDENTS
AS EARLY AS FALL TWENTY THREE
AND OTHERS WILL BE IN TWENTY
FOUR ANDTWENTY FIVE. AGAIN
THESE ARE BACHELORS AND MASTERS
AND SCIENCES IN AREAS LIKE APPLY
FIRE SCIENCE BIOTECHNOLOGY
COMPUTER AND INFORMATION.
TECHNOLOGY ENGINEERING NURSE. ON
ACCOUNT OF PRUDENT SIDE OF
HUMBOLDT OF THE CAMP STARTED
PLANNING FOR INDIVIDUAL PROJECTS
AND AN UPDATE TO ITS PHYSICAL
MASTER PLAN. I COMMUNITY HOUSING
FOR STUDENTS SEVERELY LIMITED-
ON THE NORTH COAST THEREFORE
ACQUISITION AND CONSTRUCTION OF
NEW STUDENT HOUSING IS A TOP
PRIORITY ALONG WITH A NEW
ENGINEERING SLASH HOUSING
PROJECT. APPLIED RESEARCH
PROJECTS AND FACILITY
RENOVATIONS ON FOR THOSE
DISCOUNT PROGRAMS. THE TOP-
PROJECT- PRIORITY PROJECTS ARE
SCHEDULED TO BE COMPLETED IN
LATE TWENTY TWENTY FOUR AND THEN
PERHAPS IN OTHER PROJECTS AND
FALL BY FALL TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
I WANT SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGES
NOTED BY MY COLLEAGUE BY SAN
JUAN IS THAT CONSTRUCTION COST
ESCALATION IS PRETTY SIGNIFICANT
NOT ONLY NOT AT THAT CAMPUS AND
ELSEWHERE THROUGHOUT THE STATE
NOT SHOULD BE SURPRISED AND- THE
THIRD ITEM. ON YOUR AGENDA IS
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE GRANTS TO
STUDENTS- THE BUDGET ACT
PROVIDED THIRTY MILLION TO
SUPPORT FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE
GRANTS TO LOW INCOME STUDENTS
WHO ENROLLED T LEAST HALF TIME.
THEY DEMONSTRATED AND MERGING
SEA NEED IN THEIR UNIQUE
CIRCUMSTANCES. AND DIFFERENT AT
LEAST A GRADE POINT AVERAGE OF
TWO POINT OUR RECENT TERM. ALL
THE FUNDING HAS BEEN DISPERSED
BY THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE TO
THE CAMPUS SO IT'S IN THERE WILL
HOUSE THE MOMENT. IN OUR
GUIDANCE TWO CAMPUSES WAS BASED
ON THE BUDGET ACT LANGUAGE IT
WAS YOU KNOW PRETTY COMPLICATED
TERMS IF YOU CAN AND WHAT WHO
COULD WHO COULD. BE ELIGIBLE FOR
THAT. GRANT FUNDING. NOW CAMPUS
FINANCIAL AID OFFICES ARE
PARTNERED WITH SUCH PLACES AS
THEIR BASIC NEEDS- AREAS AND
NOT. TO GET THE WORD OUT TO
STUDENTS AND SO FAR WE HAVE
ABOUT SEVENTY FOUR HUNDRED
STUDENTS RECEIVED THESE GRANTS.
ACROSS TWENTY THREE CAMPUSES. I
AND- I JUST WANT TO NOTE HERE
THAT THIS CAR THAT WAS CREATED
IS LAID INTENSIVE. IT HAS TO BE
DETERMINE ON A CASE CASE BASIS
WE HAVE STOPS. STILL WE HAVE TO
HAVE PEOPLE OUR CAMPUS IS
REACHING OUT TO STUDENTS AND
TRYING TO ASSESS WHAT THEIR
SITUATION IS. BUT THAT STATE
CAMPUSES HAVE PLANS IN PLACE TO
EXPAND THE FUNDS BY THE END OF
THE ACADEMIC YEAR. SO STILL A
WORK IN PROGRESS ON THAT ON THAT
PROGRAM. FORESEE IS THE- SALAS
SAID THIS WAY YOUR AGENDA BUT IT
IS THE GLOBAL. I HISPANIC
SERVING INSTITUTION EQUITY
INNOVATION THAT. PROGRAM HAS
CHANGED ITS NAME AND ITS ON THE
NORTHRIDGE CAMPUS. NOW THE
PURPOSE OF IT IS A FACILITY AND
ASSOCIATE KROGER PROGRAM THAT
WILL BE TO INSPIRE TRADITIONALLY
UNDERSERVED GRADES SIX THROUGH
FOURTEEN STUDENTS TO PURSUE A
STEM DEGREE. YOUR HANDS ON. IS
DESIGN PHASES AND THAT'S UNDER
WAY- THE CHALLENGE THOUGH WITH
THIS IS THAT THE TOTAL PROJECT
COST IS FORTY NINE MILLION
DOLLARS THIS POINT. AND ONE TIME
FUNDING PROVIDED THEIR BUDGET
WAS TWENTY FIVE ONE DOLLAR SO
THE NORTHRIDGE CAMPUS IS WORKING
ON FUND RAISING TO COVER THE
DIFFERENCE IN CONSTRUCTION WILL
COMMENCE WHEN THAT OCCURS. THE
ITEM IS CSU STANISLAUS. THE
STOCKTON CENTER ENROLLMENT
ISSUE. THE BUDGET ACT PROVIDED A
MILLION DOLLARS TO ENROLL AN
ADDITIONAL HUNDRED FIFTEEN
STUDENTS AT THE CENTER- STAND
STATE CONTINUES TO PROMOTE THE
STOCKTON CENTER TO ITS LOCAL
HIGH SCHOOLS AND COMMUNITY
COLLEGES LIKE DELTA COLLEGE.
LATER THIS YEAR THE CAMPUS WILL
FINISH ITS ADMISSIONS CYCLE AND
YOU HAVE A BETTER IDEA OF THE
ANTICIPATED FALL TWENTY TWENTY
TWO ENROLLMENT AT THE CENTER.
AND RIGHT NOW THE CAMPUS IS IN
THE PROCESS OF HIRING SIX FULL
TIME FACULTY THAT WILL BE SIGNED
IT STOCKTON. EXPAND CURRENT
PROGRAMS AND PREPARE NEW
PROGRAMS. AS A RESEARCH STUDY
ARE IN EDUCATION SOCIAL WORK
CHILD DEVELOPMENT IN NURSING AND
NEW PROGRAMS- NEW DEGREE
PROGRAMS WOULD BE A LOGISTICS
SUPPLY CHAIN AS WELL AS
OPERATION AND THE CAMPUS THIS
POINT IS. THAT IT WILL BE GET
BAD AND WRONG GROWTH GOAL BY THE
TWENTY TWO THREE HERE. SIX AND
FINALLY COMPUTING INITIALLY AT
SEA MONTEREY BAY. YEAH GOAL OF
THIS PROGRAM IS RECRUIT INCREASE
FIRST AND COMPLETION RATES TO
COMPETE SCIENCE MAJOR. AND
LARGELY FOR UNDERSERVED
UNDERSERVED STUDENTS. INITIALLY
THE CORPORATE SLABS CURRICULUM
WITH DIRECT CONNECTION TO THE
TECH INDUSTRY. ALSO IT'S BEEN
UNDER WAY FOR A WHILE- IT WAS A
GRANT RECIPIENT A SPECIAL WORSE
TO BE IN A FEW YEARS AGO FROM
THE GOVERNOR'S INNOVATION
AWARDS. BUT I JUST WANT TO POINT
OUT THAT THE INITIATIVE HAS
DEVELOPED PARTNERSHIPS ALREADY
WITH OTHER C. ISSUES YOU SEEM TO
BE COLLEGES AND CURRENTLY
INCLUDES ABOUT TWO HUNDRED
SEVENTY STUDENTS ACROSS FORTY
INSTITUTIONS. AND WITH IT TEN
MILLION DOLLARS WE PLAN TO
UTILIZE CAMPUS PLANS UTILIZE
THAT TWO MILLION DOLLARS OVER
THE NEXT FIVE YEARS TO SUSTAIN
THE PROGRAM EXPANDED SOMEWHAT.
NOT INCLUDE MY COMMENTS. THANKS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH US SENATOR-
TROUBLE GIVE ANY QUESTIONS ON
THE SIDE OF- JUST CLARIFICATION
PURPOSES- MR TRUMP WOULD YOU
MIND. RESETTING DID YOU SAY THAT
THERE WAS A NEW PROGRAM FOR
LOGISTICS. YES SO WHAT THE WHAT
UNDER THE STOCKTON STOCKTON
CENTER WHICH IS IN CENTER
ASSOCIATED WITH THE STANISLAUS
CAMPUS- THERE WAS A GIRL IT
REALLY GROSS- THAT WAS PROVIDED
FOR SPECIFICALLY FOR THAT
CENTER. INTO THE CAMPUS HAS
PLANS TO DEVELOP A NEW DEGREE
PROGRAM THERE IN THE CHEST X.
AND SUPPLY CHAIN. AND I'M KIND
OF CURIOUS HOW DO THEY DECIDE
THAT SPECIFICS- CAMPUS- TO
DEVELOP THE PROGRAM AND I'M I'M
ASKING JUST BECAUSE I'M FROM THE
INLAND EMPIRE. AND AS YOU CAN
IMAGINE THE INLAND BARS QUITE
THE LOGISTICS- WAREHOUSE AB HUB
FOR CALIFORNIA PER SE. AND IN MY
MIND NOT TAKING AWAY FROM
STOCKTON- BUT- WOULD HAVE BEEN A
LOGICAL CHOICE TO HAVE THEM UP
OF THIS. CALIBER IN A CAL STATE
SALMON DINO. YEAH YOU KNOW I'M
I'M NOT- REPRESENTING THE
ACADEMIC AND STUDENT- SIDE OF
OUR HOUSE THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE SO I DON'T HAVE THE DEPTH
OF KNOWLEDGE THAT I'M ONE OF MY
COLLEAGUES COULD PERHAPS PROVIDE
YOU BUT ESSENTIALLY THE
SHORTHANDED GOALS IS THAT
WHENEVER THERE IS A DESIRE TO
DEVELOP A NEW ACADEMIC PROGRAMS
IT ORIGINATES AT THE CAMPUS IN
ERECTING ORIGINATES WITH THE-
THE ACADEMIC FACULTY AS WELL AS
THE ADMINISTRATORS ON CAMPUSES.
NOW THE CHALLENGE OF COURSE IS
THAT YOU NEED FUNDING IN ORDER
TO. HIGHER FACULTY AND STAFF TO
SUPPORT THOSE TYPES OF PROGRAMS.
AND WHEN YOU HAVE A NUMBER OF
EXISTING DEGREE PROGRAMS AND
NUMBER FACULTIES SPECIALIZE IN
THOSE OTHER DEGREE PROGRAMS DOES
TAKE A LITTLE WHILE TO DEVELOP
THOSE PROGRAMS. SO IN THIS
PARTICULAR CASE THAT STANDS
STATE WE HAVE THAT- OPPORTUNITY
BECAUSE OF ENROLLMENT GROWTH TO-
YOU KNOW. EXPAND PRETTY PRETTY
CREATIVE BRANDING PROGRAM HERE
THE STOCKTON CENTER. BUT I THINK
WHAT WHAT FROM YOUR VANTAGE
POINT WOULD BE WOULD BE IF IT
STARTS AT THE GRASSROOTS ON
CAMPUS AND THEN- PERCOLATES UP.
THOSE PROGRAMS ARE THEN IF THERE
EXAMPLE ON JEOPARDY THERE'S
DESIRE TO CREATE A SIMILAR
LOGISTICS SUPPLY CHAIN DEGREE
PROGRAM. THAT WOULD BE SOMETHING
THAT THE KIDS THAT THE CAMPUS
WOULD PUSH UP TO THE CHANCES
OFFICE ALTERNATELY THE TRUSTEES
APPROVED. THOSE NEW DEGREE
PROGRAMS- AND THEN THEY COULD
GET GOING TRANSPIRING DEVELOPING
SO I'M SURE IF YOU ASKED AT
PRESENT TO MOST ROBUST AT
SAMPOERNA DINO I'M SURE HE HAS
SEVERAL PROGRAMS HE SAID HE
WOULD LOVE TO LAUNCH. HOWEVER
THIS IS A LIMITATION TERMS OF
NOT OF MONEY YOU CAN DO IN ORDER
TO TAKE MARCHES PROGRAMS I WILL
SAY ONE OTHER THING I WOULD JUST
SAY WELL PLAYED. WELL PLAYED
VERY SO WELL THE OTHER THING TO
OF COURSE IS THAT- THERE'S
DEMAND STUDIES TO THAT CAMPUS IS
PURSUED THE CITY LOOK TO SEE
WHETHER THERE'S ACTUALLY DEMAND
ON ON A PARTICULAR CAMPUSES. FOR
THOSE TYPES OF DEGREES BEFORE
THE LAUNCH THEY DON'T WANT TO
WANT SOMETHING NOBODY SHOWS SO
THAT'S. ANOTHER ASPECT TO.
WELCOME FIRST FROM HELP ME UNDER
. THIS IS THE DAY. COMFORT THIS
THE- HOW DO YOU HOW DO YOU. S.
THE DEMAND IS WHAT I'M SAYING
WITHOUT A PER AND- YOU CAN. JUST
IT REALLY STARTS WITH THE CAMPUS
THEY CAN'T COMMUNITY. ARE BOTH
THE BACK. THERE AS WELL AS THAT
THE CAMPUS. YEAH NOW ALL OF THEM
OBVIOUSLY HOUSE HAVE THEIR
FINGERS. ON PULSE WOULD HAVE
LOCAL- AND SO. THEY WOULD DO
KNOW WHETHER THEY TO. IT MAKES
SENSE TO. PROGRAMS SO- BUT IT'S
THE CAMP. PERFECT ALL KEEP THAT
IN MY- I WOULD LOVE TO SEE A-
SUCH AS THAT IN IN OUR AREA TO.
OUR LOCAL. JOB. JOB REQUIREMENTS
THE YOU. THANK YOU VERY. AND I
JUST HAVE A COLUMN. ABOUT- ONE
IS A- IS THAT. ARE WITH REGARD
TO WHAT'S CENTER ROADSHOW BOGUE
JUST ASKED IT'S BECOME REALLY
CLEAR TO ME. THIS YEAR THAT.
THERE CAL STATE UNIVERSITY
SYSTEMATIC DIFFERENT KIND OF
PRIORITY. ASSESS FOR THEIR
BUDGET WHICH IS THEY'RE ALLOWING
THE INDIVIDUAL CAMPUSES TO GO
DIRECTLY TO LEGISLATORS FOR
ITEMS THAT ARE NOT. IN THE CSU'S
OVERALL REQUESTED SO THAT'S WHY
I SAID WELL PLAYED HE WAS
SERVING YOU UP TO THAT PROCESS
WHEN HE- HE MADE THAT COMMENT.
SENATOR I MUST INTERRUPT. WE
WANT TO BE SPECIFIC THAT THIS IS
ONLY RELATED TO ONE TIME FUNDING
- WE ARE VERY COGNIZANT OF THE
FACT THAT WE NEED TO FIND OUR
RECURRING SPENDING BUDGET
REQUESTS CONSISTENT WITH THE
BOARD WEALTHY ARE YOU. REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT- THAT ADDITION
THAT IS EXACTLY TRUE AND- IN OUR
APPRECIATE YOUR COURAGE AND
INTERRUPTING THE CHAIRS WILL A
SECOND WEEK- D. R. I WANTED TO
SAY THAT THERE'S AN INTERESTING
SUBTEXT TO WHAT'S THE STORY OF
THEHOUR WITH REGARD TO CAL
STATE. STANISLAUS AND THE
STOCKTON CENTER IS THAT BEFORE
WE HAD THE LAWSUIT IT'S GOTTEN
ALL THE HEADLINES AT UC BERKELEY
ABOUT ENROLLMENT. WE WERE ASKING
AT THIS COMMITTEE. ON HOW NOT.
J. JAM ALL EXIST AND RUN INTO
CURRENT PLACE AND HOW TO HAVE.
FOR EXPANSION AND THAT THE STATE
. REFERRED TO CAL. APART IN THE
PRESS. OUR ARMED AT STAR IS A
WAY TO. ADDRESSED THE HAVE SENT
THAT ARE LOW. THAT THE L.
EXISTING. THAT MIGHT BE.
GENERALLY BUILT OUT AT THEIR
MAIN LOCATIONS AND- GROWTH IN A
WAY THAT SERVES COMMUNITIES
BETTER AT AND SO THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT I THINK WE WERE
TALKING ABOUT BEFORE THE LAWSUIT
KLOPP THIS WHOLE ISSUE ON THE-
THE FRONT PAGE. AND THEN THE
THIRD THING THAT I WOULD SAY IS
I'M SURE THAT THERE SOME PEOPLE
WATCHING AT HOME. THAT WONDER
WHY WE WENT THROUGH THIS LIST
AND THAT LIST WAS THE IMPORTANT
EXERCISE IN ITSELF BECAUSE- WE
OF THE LEGISLATURE HAVE TO
PROVIDE OVERSIGHT AND HOW DO WE
MAKE SURE. THAT THINGS ARE BEING
SPENT WE APPROPRIATE AND JUST AS
MR STORM MADE THE COMMENT ABOUT
ONE TIME FUNDING THESE WERE ONE
TIME FUNDING ITEMS FROM LAST
YEAR'S BUDGET. FOR THE CURRENT
BUDGET YEAR AND THIS IS OUR WAY
JUST BY THE FACT THAT HE HAD TO
GO THROUGH EACH ONE AND REPORT
THE PROGRESS IT'S OUR WAY OF
DOING THE OVERSIGHT AND MAKING
SURE THAT. THE LIGHT SHINES ON
WHAT ARE APPROPRIATIONS WERE AND
HOW THEY ARE BEING IMPLEMENTED
SO- I APPRECIATE EVERYBODY BEING
PRESIDENT. OF FOR THIS ITEM AND-
THANK YOU AND THANK YOU FOR THE
REPORTS IN THE STATE'S. WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE TO. ISSUE NUMBER
ELEVEN. WHICH IS INFORMATION
IMPLEMENTATION OF BUDGET ACT
AGREEMENTS AND OVERSIGHT JUST AS
THE LAST ITEM BUT THIS TIME FOR
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEM AND THE PANEL SAID TO
CONSIST IN ITS ENTIRETY OF
LISETTE NAVARETTE FROM THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE- OF WELCOME
TO THE COMMITTEE. THANK YOU
CHAIR. CHAIRMAN LAYERED- AND
SENATOR- CHEWABLE WAS THAT EVER
AN EXECUTIVE YOU INSERT THE
CALIFORNIA COLLEGES. HELPING
COLLEGES ARE UNIQUELY POSITIONED
TO HELP RESIDENTS FROM ALL
BACKGROUNDS IMPROVE THEIR SOCIAL
AND ECONOMIC MOBILITY FOR THEIR
THEMSELVES AND THEIR FAMILIES.
VERY GLAD THAT THE COMMITTEE HAS
MADE SEVERAL AND BASS INVESTMENT
IN BASIC NEEDS THE COMMITTEE
EXPRESSED INTEREST IN RECEIVING
IMPLEMENTATION UPDATE ON FIVE
ITEMS BASIC NEEDS TO STUDENT
MENTAL HEALTH. ZERO TEXTBOOK
COST AGREES FULL TIME FACULTY AN
EQUAL EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITY
PROGRAM FUNDING IN THE INTEREST
OF TIME I HAVE PROVIDED A
WRITTEN IMPLEMENTATION UPDATE
BUT I WILL COVER A FEW HIGH
LEVEL POINTS ON EACH OF THESE
ITEMS. THE FIRST IS AROUND BASIC
NEEDS- THESE RESOURCES A BEN
ESSENTIAL THAT- BUDGET INCLUDES
A HUNDRED MILLION ONE TIME FOR
CALIFORNIA CAN COLLEGES TO
PROVIDE COMPREHENSIVE BASIC
NEEDS SERVICES. IN OUR
IMPLEMENTATION WE'VE COUPLED
THIS WITH AN INVESTMENT THAT WAS
ALSO MADE BY THE LEGISLATURE FOR
THIRTY MILLION IN BASIC NEEDS
CENTERS. THE GOAL IS TO- BIRD
USE EQUITY AND ACHIEVEMENT GAPS
UNDER AMONGST ON A TRADITIONALLY
UNDERREPRESENTED STUDENT
POPULATIONS TO SUPPORT BASIC
NEEDS HELP MAINTAIN FOOD
PANTRIES AND ASSIST STUDENTS
WITH- CALFRESH ENROLLMENT-
SECURE HOUSING AMONGST OTHER
CORE NEEDS THAT STUDENTS HAVE
IDENTIFIED. THE TEAMSTERS OFFICE
UTILIZED A SOCIAL DETERMINANTS
OF EDUCATIONAL SUCCESS FRAMEWORK
AND GUIDING ITS BASIC NEEDS
SYSTEM WIDE INITIATIVES I
PROVIDED MORE BACKGROUND ON WHAT
THIS FRAMEWORK IS AND HOW WE'RE
UTILIZING IT TO LEVERAGE LONG
TERM INVESTMENTS IN SUPPORT- IN
SHORT IT FOCUSES ON FINANCIAL
STABILITY. HOLDEN MENTAL HEALTH
AND SUPPORT NETWORKS- BETTER.
QUARTER TO THE SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS FOR OR EDUCATE SIX-
ITS- EARLY ON IN SOME OF THE-
MEASURES AND DATA. IN DOUBLE.
CURRENTLY FIFTY. OTHER COLLEGES
ALREADY ESTABLISHED PHYSICAL
BASIC NEEDS CENTERS AND- THE
MAJORITY OF THEM HAVE- INCLUDED
ALL THE DETAILS NEEDED- IN THEIR
WEBSITES FOR BASIC NEEDS
SERVICES AND OTHER COURSE AS
INDICATED IN THAT BUDGET
INVESTMENT. LET ME SHARE A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES I'M OVER IN THE FALL WE
CONDUCTED A TOUR OF EIGHT
COLLEGES AND I CAN EMPHASIZE
THIS IS ONE OF THE AREAS
STUDENTS IDENTIFIED MOST NEEDING
ESPECIALLY AS THEY AND THEIR
FAMILIES RECOVER FROM THIS
ENDEMIC. THE TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO BUDGET PROVIDED ON GOING
FUNDS OF THIRTY MILLION WE'RE
VERY GRATEFUL FOR THESE ON GOING
FUNDS I WE'VE ALLOCATED THESE
RESOURCES ALREADY PROVIDING
DISTRICTS BASED FUNDING OF SIXTY
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS. PLUS THE
REMAINING BALANCE APPROPRIATED
ACCORDING TO THIS TOTAL
HEADCOUNT OF THAT OF DISTRICT
AND- ON STUDENT NEED- LOOKING AT
HEALTH AS THE MEASURE. WE'VE
ALSO IN CALL TO LEVERAGE THEIR
GUIDED PATHWAYS FRAMEWORK TO USE
THESE FUNDS TO DESIGN AND
DELIVER REALLY DELIVERY MODEL
THAT IS CONNECTED TO OTHER CORE
ACADEMIC AND ON SUPPORT SERVICES
ULTIMATELY HELPING THEM SUCCEED
. THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE- ALSO
MEAN VERY RESOURCES ON THE
HEALTH AND WELLNESS WEBSITE AND
WE CONTINUE AND WILL OFFER MORE
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT TO SEE
THIS COLLEGES AND IMPLEMENTATION
COLLEGES REPORT ANNUALLY ON
THESE FUNDS. LET ME SHARE ABOUT
ZERO TEXTBOOK COST AGREES OUR
GOALS AND IMPLEMENTATION OF ZERO
TEST CLUSTER GREASE ARCH REDUCE
THE OVERALL COST OF EDUCATION
DECREASE TIME TO COMPLETION.
ARTIST I REQUEST FOR APPLICATION
IS OUT I'M INTERESTED COLLEGES
AND- THOSE DISTRICTS WILL
RECEIVE TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR EACH DEGREE THAT DAY
THAT THEY DEVELOP AND MEETS THE
CRITERIA. WILL SHARE MORE- AS WE
EMBARK ON THIS WORK WE ARE
CREATING A TASK FORCE TO EXAMINE
SYSTEMIC TEXTBOOK AFFORDABILITY
ISSUES AND I WILL BE HAPPY TO
SHARE THOSE RECOMMENDATIONS AS
THE TASK FORCE COMPLETED WORK.
LET ME MOVE TO INVESTMENT IN
FACULTY THE BUDGET ACT- OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE PROVIDED A
HUNDRED MILLION I'M GOING TO
HIRE NEW FULL TIME FACULTY IN
ORDER TO INCREASE THE PERCENTAGE
OF FULL TIME FACULTY TOWARDS
MEETING THE 7525% GOAL DISTRICTS
HAD THE OPTION TO ELECT TO
DECLINE THE ALLOCATION. OF THESE
FUNDS A TOTAL OF SEVENTY TWO OR
IT ARE A SEVENTY OVER SEVENTY
TWO DISTRICTS ELECTED TO ACCEPT
THE FUNDS AND THOSE WERE
DISTRIBUTED- IN THE SUMMER IN
LATE SUMMER SO THAT COLLEGES AND
DISTRICTS COULD BEGIN HIRING-
IMMEDIATELY. THE MECCA TO
MEASURE TWENTY SEVEN FIVE TWENTY
GOAL. AND FROM MY- COMPLY. IS TO
THE FACT OF NUMBER KNOWN AS THE
FOR. DISTRICTS MUST WITH- FULL
TIME. ON DATA ANNUALLY AND WE-
DISTRICTS I WORK TOWARDS MEETING
THEIR FACULTY APPLICATION NUMBER
IN VANCE FALL REPORTING. LET ME
CONCLUDE BY PROVIDING AN UPDATE
ON EQUAL EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITY
PRACTICES THEIR BUDGET PROVIDED
TWENTY MILLION ONE TIME- FOR THE
TEAMSTERS OFFICE IN THE BOARD OF
GOVERNORS TO ALLOCATE TO SUPPORT
IMPLEMENTATION OF BEST
PRACTICES. UTILIZING THE
MULTIPLE METHODS- MODEL ON THIS
METHOD FOCUSES ON HIRING SPREE
HIRING HIRING AND HOST HIRING. I
THESE RESOURCES ARE CRITICAL WE
USUALLY ONLY HAVE FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR EACH DISTRICT- TO
IMPLEMENT THE E. O. PROGRAMS
EQUAL EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITY
PROGRAMS. HOWEVER THESE FUNDS
PROVIDED- AN OPPORTUNITY TO
EMPLOYMENT PRACTICES THAT CAN
ALSO COMPLEMENT THE HIRING THAT
IS HAPPENING AROUND FULL TIME
FACULTY OR OTHER OR SUPPORT.
THEIR- IF YOUR- FOR BACKGROUND.
IN ORDER TO GET E. O. FOR
DISTRICTS THREE. ON PENALTIES
FOR NOT MEETING THEIR FACULTY
OBLIGATION NUMBER INSTEAD THIS
OUTDATED AND COUNTERPRODUCTIVE
OF FORMULA MEANT THAT- IN ORDER
TO- HIRED UNDER EQUAL EMPLOYMENT
DISTRICTS WERE INSTEAD- FOCUSED
ON NOT NEEDING ANOTHER CORE
MEASURE FOR THESE REASONS WE
BELIEVE THAT AN ONGOING
ALLOCATION TO FURTHER ADVANCE
YOUR PRACTICES. AS PROPOSED IN
THE TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE
BUDGET IS A FACTOR FOR A LONG
TERM STRATEGY THAT PROVIDES
PLANING ACCOUNTABILITY AND
SOLIDIFIES EFFECTIVE PRACTICES
ACROSS ALL OF OUR INSTITUTIONS.
I HOPE THIS IS HELPFUL AGAIN
MORE DETAILS ARE PROVIDED IN
OTHER WRITTEN UPDATED HAPPY
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THE SENATE ROADSHOW
BUGTI OF QUESTIONS ON THE SIDE.
YES I DO THANK YOU SO MUCH AS I
CAN ABOUT THE FOR YOUR REPORT I
HAD A QUESTION WITH THE FULL
TIME AND PART TIME FACULTY
BECAUSE I. SORT OF. ADDRESS THE-
IN OUR PAST COMMITTEE HEARINGS
AND IN THE SENSE THAT YOU KNOW
WE HAVE THIS EXPECTATION OF
SCHOOLS HAVING A CERTAIN TYPE OF
ENROLLMENT AND THEN TRY TO
FIGURE OUT OKAY WELL WE HAVE THE
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE WE HAVE
FACILITIES THAT WE HAVE TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE HAVE AVAILABLE TO
BE ABLE TO ACCOMMODATE THE
STUDENTS BUT MY ALL BUT THE
OTHER CONCERNING QUESTION WAS
WITH REGARDS TO THE FACULTY
ESPECIALLY RIGHT NOW. IN
POSITION WITH THEM YES THE
SHORTAGES THAT WE HAVE IN IN
EDUCATION SO MY QUESTION WAS THE
FOLLOWING WHAT IS CONSIDERED A
FULL TIME FACULTY- AT AT THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES IS IT BASED
ON THE NUMBER OF CLASSES THAT
THEY'RE THEY'RE TEACHING OR IS
IT BASED ON THE NUMBER OF
STUDENTS- THAT THEY THEY'RE
THEY'RE SERVING BECAUSE OF
COURSE- AS A FORMER TEACHER I
UNDERSTAND THAT YOU KNOW. EACH
STUDENT TAKES SOME TIME
SPECIALLY AT THE COLLEGE LEVEL
I'M IS SO JUST GONNA HERE IS
WHAT IS CONSIDERED A FULL TIME
FACULTY- AT AT. AT YOUR AT YOUR
SCHOOL. YEAH COLLEGES- FULL TIME
. IS KIND- BASED ON. THEIR
TEACHER LOW. SO SINCE. AT THAT
THE TIME CREDIT HOURS OF DIRT
FOUR HOURS AFTER. THAT'S NOT
MEASURED. ON THE NUMBER OF
STUDENTS THEY SERVE INSTEAD IS
REALLY LOOKING AT THEIR CLASS
LOAD. IN CLASS LOAD YOU MEAN HOW
MANY. COURSES THAT THEY'RE
TEACHING. YEAH THAT'S LOOKING AT
THE CLASSES THAT THEY'RE
TEACHING AS WELL AS- THE TIME
THAT THAT CLASS NEEDS SO WE DO
HAVE SOME BETTER FOR EXAMPLE
THREE UNIT CLASSES AS OPPOSED TO
ONE UNIT CLASSES. FOR THE- CLASS
LOAD IS MEASURED DIFFERENTLY FOR
THOSE- BUT- THE A FACULTY
MEMBER- HAS A CERTAIN AMOUNT OF
HOURS THAT THEY NEED IN ORDER TO
ACHIEVE BEING A FULL TIME
FACULTY STATUS. AND WHAT WHAT'S
THE NUMBER FOR THOSE CLASS WHAT
IS THAT KIND OF LOOKS LOOK LIKE.
WE HAVE- AND I'M DRAWING A BLANK
RIGHT NOW BUT I POLICY HIS- SO
THE FACULTY LOAD HOURS IT THE
RACE FIVE. IN AND IT'S TOTAL
HOURS. IS THAT SEMESTER PER YEAR
. PER SEMESTER. AND WE- HAPPY TO
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL DETAILS ON-
THAT CALCULATION HOW IT'S
MEASURED- IF THAT WOULD BE
HELPFUL AND USEFUL CONTACTS IT
WOULD BE JUST BECAUSE IT GIVES
ME AN IDEA AS TO HOW MANY. FIRST
OF ALL HOW MANY FACULTY YOU
FOLKS HIGHER WITH THE AMOUNT OF
MONEY THAT IS BEING ALLOCATED AS
WELL AS HOW MANY STUDENTS WILL
BE POTENTIALLY SERVING AND HOW
MANY CLASSES WILL BE AVAILABLE
IN ORDER TO ACCOMMODATE- YOU
KNOW MUCH OF THE CONCERNS THAT
WE HEAR FROM STUDENTS THAT
THEY'RE NOT. ABLE TO. GET THE
CLASSES THAT THEY NEED IN ORDER
TO GRADUATE ON TIME SO THIS IS
JUST A LITTLE BIT. FOR ME UP
JUST A LITTLE HELPFUL IT MIGHT
BE FOR AUDIENCE AS WELL TO.
UNDERSTAND WHAT IT TAKES TO. TO
WHAT TYPE OF TEACHERS WE ARE HOW
MANY TEACHERS THAT WE NEED-
CLASSES DO WE NEED. AND THE
STUDENTS THAT WE CAN ACTUALLY.
READILY AND APPROPRIATELY F. AB
OFFICIALLY SERVE- IN OUR SCHOOLS
SO THANK YOU SO MUCH I WOULD
APPRECIATE THAT. ABSOLUTELY
WE'LL FOLLOW UP WITH THAT FREE-
FOR CONTEXT AND EXPLANATION AND
HAPPY TO. SEE YOU- ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS FOLLOWING MEMORY. OKAY
THANK YOU ASCENDER I HAVE A
COUPLE OF QUESTIONS IN THE FIRST
ONE IS AS YOU REPORTED ON THE
STUDENT BASIC NEEDS ALLOCATION
BASED ON LAST YEAR'S. A ONE TIME
PROP NINETY EIGHT PROPOSAL AND
WHILE IT DOESN'T REQUIRE A
REPORT ON JANUARY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE. MORE BEING PRESSED
IN THIS BUDGET TO DO ORE FOR
BASIC STUDENT NEEDS THOSE ARE
WHY THERE MIGHT BE IN TERM
REPORT SO THAT WE KNOW WHAT'S
BEEN DONE IN THE BUDGET HERE AND
THEN IF WE ARE BEING ASKED TO DO
SOMETHING ADDITIONAL. WE HAVE AN
IDEA HOW WE MATCH YOU WITH
WHAT'S ALREADY BEEN DONE.
ABSOLUTELY CURRENTLY WE
CONDUCTED A SURVEY TO GET A
SENSE OF- HOW MANY DISTRICTS
HAVE IMPLEMENTED. AND ESTABLISH
THEIR BASIC NEEDS CENTERS WE CAN
FOLLOW UP IN VARIOUS SURVEYS TO
GET A SENSE- IMPLEMENTATION. ON
ONE AREA WE HAVE SEEN VERY
POSITIVE IS AROUND ACCORDING IN
MAKING- BASIC NEEDS RESOURCES
AVAILABLE- PROMINENTLY. ON
WEBSITE SO THAT STUDENTS CAN
FIND THEM AS YOU KNOW WEBSITES
NOW OR IN MANY WAYS THE WELCOME
CENTER FOR COLLEGES- MY STUDENTS
TURN TO THOSE FOR. MORE
INFORMATION SO. WE'LL GET WE CAN
FOLLOW UP ON- STATUS UPDATES- IN
ADVANCE OF ME REVISED. OKAY WE
APPRECIATE THAT AND THEN. THE
NEW SORRY I CAN EVEN WHAT THE
ACRONYM FUND STANDS FOR- FACULTY
OBLIGATION NUMBER OKAY. M. BUT
UNDERSTAND THE CONCEPT ABOUT THE
WHAT THE ACRONYM WAS FOR BECAUSE
THE BUDGET ACT YOU MENTIONED
THAT IT. IS DESIGNED SINCE IN
SMALL PART TO ADDRESS THAT AND
SO. THE THE INCREASE IN HIRING
FULL TIME FACULTY HOW WILL YOU
BE ABLE TO TELL. WHETHER OR NOT
THAT'S AFFECTED THAT NUMBER AT
THE DIFFERENT CAMPUSES I MEAN DO
YOU KNOW ALREADY THAT ARE YOU
WAITING TO COMPILE THAT DATA HOW
WILL THAT- BE CLEAR. WE HAVE A
TO SHARE MORE DETAILS SO
DISTRICTS HAVE TO REPORT ON
SOMETHING CALLED THERE THE IS
YOU KNOW THAT FACULTY OBLIGATION
NUMBER THEY DO THIS EVERY YEAR
SO IN ORDER TO- FOR THOSE
DISTRICTS THAT DID ACCEPT THE
FULL TIME FACULTY FUNDS THEY
ALSO ACCEPTED THEIR FACULTY
OBLIGATION NUMBER INCREASING AND
THEY HAVE TO REPORT ON PROGRESS
TOWARDS MEETING THAT INCREASES
BY FALL OF EACH YEAR IN SO- WE
EXPECT THAT DATED TO COMMAND
MOST HIRING HOPPER HAPPENS
AROUND THE SPRING TERM. AND SO
WE KNOW THAT DISTRICTS ARE BUT I
GET THE GIST OF IT IS THAT YOU
WANT NOW BY THE TIME OF THE MAY
REVISE IF THOSE THAT ACCEPTED
MONEY ON THIS ONE FACT HAVEN'T
CHANGED FACULTY OBLIGATION
NUMBER- THE FACT. OBLIGATION DID
GO ON WHAT WE KNOW BY FALL IS
WHETHER THEY PER COMPLIANCE WITH
THAT INCREASE THAT IS REQUIRED.
SO WE DON'T KNOW OR DON'T
UNDERSTAND THAT. SO YOU HAVE THE
FACTS BUT YOU DON'T KNOW IF THEY
COMPLIED. YES WE MEASURE
COMPLIANCE IN THE FALL TO ENABLE
TIME- FOR HIRING. I'M NOT HIRING
HAPPENS AROUND THIS HERO EVEN
THOUGH YOU EXCUSE ME FOR
INTERRUPTING EVEN THOUGH YOU
HAVE THE NUMBERS AND- IT IN THE
SPRING YOU WON'T KNOW IF THEY
COMPLIED TOTAL FALL. ABSOLUTELY
SO WE WON'T BE ABLE TO MAKE AN
ASSESSMENT OF. WHETHER THIS
MONEY ACCOMPLISHED ITS PURPOSE
BY THE TIME OF THE MAY REVISE.
THAT'S CORRECT OKAY CORRECT BUT
UNFORTUNATE. BUT I APPRECIATE
THAT. SO ARE THERE ANY MORE
QUESTIONS HERE. THEN ONCE YOU
TURN YOUR MICROPHONE AND ASK
YOUR PHONE SO JUST- SO JUST
CONNECT ADDRESSES JUST MOVING
FORWARD IN THIS COMEY SYMONETTE
I'M HERE NEXT YEAR BUT STILL
LOOKING AT. FOLLOWING UP WHETHER
OR NOT. THEY WERE COMPLIANT OR
NOT THAT TYPE OF INFORMATION
WOULD BE HELPFUL FOR US TO
FOLLOW UP NEXT YEAR YES AND I
THINK WHAT I'M GOING TO. TAKE
THE RISK OF ANSWERING THE
QUESTION SO THE THING ABOUT IT
IS THAT WILL BE EVIDENT IN THE
FALL OF BY THE TIME WE- WE HAVE
THIS HEARING NEXT YEAR IT SHOULD
BE SHOULD BE ANOTHER. THE N.
ACTUALLY COURSE THE COMMITTEE
WOULD LOVE TO HAVE IT. IF IT
COMES IN IN THE FALL BEFORE WE
START MEETING AGAIN BUT- THAT'S
EXACTLY WHAT. THEN LET ME THANK
YOU AND MAKE THE COMMENT AGAIN
THAT FOR THOSE THAT ARE WATCHING
AT HOME THAT THIS WAS AS MUCH
ABOUT OVERSIGHT AND HAVING THE
REPORTERS ABOUT THE SPECIFIC
QUESTION SO. WILL MOVE ON TO
ITEM NUMBER TWELVE. WHICH IS THE
DREAMER SERVICE INCENTIVE FOR
GRANTED THE CALIFORNIA STUDENT
AID COMMISSION AND WE HAVE ON
THE PANEL. GABRIELA CHAVEZ FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE JERRY
BREMNER FROM THE CALIFORNIA
STUDENT AID COMMISSION. AND LISA
CAME FROM THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE. WELCOME TO THE
COMMITTEE WILL START WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THE
MORNING W. LIKE CHÁVEZ BUT THAT
OF FINANCE- ONE SECOND I'M
HAVING SOME TECHNICAL ISSUES
HERE. HOW THE COMPANY'S BY DID
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE TO MODIFY
THE COCHRAN BE TREMENDOUS
SERVICE INTENDED GROUND PROGRAM
TO INCREASE PARTICIPANTS BY
BANDS FROM THE QUIBBLING OF TEN
DOLLARS OUT WAGE SO THEY QUIT IN
OFFICE NON AN HOUR WAGE. AND
ALLOW ANY AND IT'S- AND IT ANY
EXPENSE FUNDS. TO BE PROVIDED TO
THE UC. NCO TO SUPPORT THAT.
DREAM NONPROFIT. THANK AND I'LL
BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR MY ON TO
MISTER BURN FROM THE CALIFORNIA
STOOD NAY COMMISSION. GOOD
MORNING LAYERED AND OKAY ABOVE
GOOD TO BE BACK WITH YOU- MISTER
COMMISSION IS VERY. FOR ALL. TO
THIS SERVICE INSIDE OF HER
PROGRAM AND HELP OUR- CALIFORNIA
DREAMIN FILER. MOST OF ARE UNDER
. STUDENTS ACTS TO FINANCIAL AID
AND PROVIDE DEVELOPMENT
OPPORTUNITIES TO THE COMMUNITY
SERVICE THAT THEY UNDERTAKE
THROUGH THIS PROGRAM. WE'RE ALSO
APPRECIATIVE OF THE PROPOSED
CHANGES IN THE ADMINISTRATION'S-
BUDGET TO HELP ADDRESS ONE OF
THE ISSUES THAT WE'VE HEARD
CONSISTENTLY FROM OUR CAMPUS
PARTNERS IN THIS FIRST YEAR
TREATMENT PLANTATION OF THIS
PROGRAM. AROUND THE- THE AMOUNT
OF THE FINANCIALLY THAT'S
PROVIDED TO STUDENTS AND IN
RETURN FOR THE COMPLETION OF
THEIR SERVICE HOURS. AND START
TO SPEAK TO SOME OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT THE L. A.
R. WAS PROVIDED IN THEIR
ANALYSIS BUT I SUSPECT OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM ILLEGAL SPEECH
JUST A MOMENT WE AGREED WITH THE
RECOMMENDATION THAT THERE SHOULD
BE A FOR THE REVISION OF THE
STATUTORY PROVISIONS. AROUND THE
REDUCTION OF AWARDS FOR PART
TIME ENROLLED STUDENTS MRS BEEN
ANOTHER CONSISTENT POINT OF
FEEDBACK THAT WE'VE HEARD FROM
OUR CAMPUS PARTNERS DOES THEY'VE
BEEN TRYING TO BRING THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO- STUDENTS WHO MAY
BE ELIGIBLE IN OUR CALIFORNIA
DREAM ACT FILERS. AND THEN
FINALLY WALL WE JUST TO MAKE
COMMISSION DON'T HAVE DATA ON
THE DREAM LOAN PROGRAM THAT IS
ADMINISTERED BY UC AND CSU
CAMPUSES- I DID JUST WANT TO
POINT OUT THAT THE FACTORS THE
DAILY AS- UPLIFTED IN THEIR
ANALYSIS AROUND. THE
PARTICIPATION RATES IN BETWEEN
ONE PROGRAMS OVER THE PAST
SEVERAL YEARS MAY SHIFT OVER THE
NEXT COUPLE YEARS AS WE SEE A
RETURN TO ON CAMPUS LIVING
STATUS FOR STUDENTS. WHO HAVE
BEEN AT HOME AND DISTANCE
LEARNING DURING THE PANDEMIC.
AND WE ALSO ANTICIPATE THERE
WILL NOT BE THE SAME LEVEL OF
INVESTMENT AND EMERGENCY
FINANCIAL AID- THAT CAME ABOUT
AS A RESULT OF COKE IN NINETEEN.
I'M AND IT'S BEEN VERY LIKELY
OFFSETTING- BUT- DREAMLAND. THAT
THESE MIGHT. WE'RE ON WE KNOW
THAT UNDOCKED STUDENTS FOR.
DREAM FILER BASIS DEEPER.
AFFORDABILITY THAN PEERS BECAUSE
OF THEIR LACK ELEGY. FOR
FINANCIAL AID AND THE- ONE PER
HAS BEEN A REALLY IMPORTANT TO
HELP FILL THAT GAP. AND ENSURE
THAT THEIR FINANCIAL AID
PACKAGES CAN BE. OFFSET FOR THAT
LACK OF FEDERAL GRANT AID OR
EVEN FEDERAL SUBSIDIZED LOANS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND WILL
MOVE TO. A LISA CAME FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
THANK YOU FOR COMING THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE I SHED TEARS ACTUALLY
TWO COMPONENTS THAT THIS
PROPOSAL ONE THAT WOULD INCREASE
THE AWARD AMOUNT IN THE TRAVERSE
FROM CENTCOM PROGRAM AND ANOTHER
THAT WAY BE CORRECT ANY UNSPENT
FUNDS FROM PROGRAM. THREE MONTH. REGARDING POSTING IN AWARENESS
. WE THINK THAT THIS IS THE
REASON WAY HER PARKING. IN A
THAT'S VERY AFTER SO. FOR TAKE
BY PROVIDING THE- TO FIFTY
DOLLARS HOUR TO STUDENTS PER. AS
PROGRAM WE THINK THAT WOULD
ALLOW THE PROBE TO. THE STUDENTS
AT A RATE THAT'S MORE SIMILAR TO
WHAT THE WOULD RECEIVE THROUGH
OTHER OF WORK. DR THIS PROPOSAL
THAT WHEN THE MARKET. I THE
COMMISSION PREVIOUSLY. UNDER THE
GOVERNOR PROPOSAL TIME STUDENTS
BUT STILL RECEIVE PRO RATED.
MEANING THAT A STUDENT HAVE TO
RECEIVE GIFTS OF AND KIND OF AND
FIFTY OUT IN DEFENSE PER HOUR
SERVICE. WE THINK THE BEST WAY
TO LIKELY TO LOADING HER CART
STUDENTS PARTICIPATE THE PROGRAM
AND MOREOVER WE SEE AS RATION
FOR. PART KINDS AT A LOW HOURLY
RATE THEIR SERVICE AND FULL TIME
. AND RECOMMENDED A PER. OF THE
HOUSE FOR PARKS STUDENTS. ONE OF
THE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
INTERPRETER TWENTY. FOR JUST
INSTEAD OF CASTING LINES. YOU
SEEN IF YOU'RE RENTING TWICE IN
THE CURRENT FUNDING LAW FOR THIS
. HAS BEEN SUFFICIENT TO MEET TO
MEET. AT THIS TIME IS. I HAVING
TO. WAY LESSER STUDENTS AWAY
FROM THE PROGRAM. IN THE BASED
ON A AND- WE SEEN A DEMONSTRATE
NEED FOR ADDITIONAL FUNDING AND. NOT REASON WE RECOMMEND REJECT
. THE REDIRECTION OF FUNDS FOR
SERVICES OF GRAN. DIFFERENT ONES
. MORE INFORMATION COMES IN THE
ON HE THE SERVICES OF PARENT.
THE LEGISLATURE MADE TO RE ON
FUNDING LEVEL CAN PROGRAM TO
ENSURE THAT IT'S A LINE DEMAND
AND THAT THERE ARE MAKES I'M
TIME IN THIS PROGRAM AND EACH
YEAR. AND YOU'RE SEEING DONALD
PAGE SEVEN THAT WE RECOGNIZE-
HARM ANDTO COMPLY IS JUST.
MAYBE THAT ALL OF YOU OF
KNOWLEDGE THAT THAT'S AN ISSUE
AND A GOOD KNOWLEDGE THAT SOME
OF THE PROPOSALS THIS YEAR OR
DECIDE TO ADDRESS IT SO I WOULD
JUST SAY THAT. THAT OUR HOPE IS
TO BE ABLE TO MEASURE THAT. ARE
WOULD BE SUPPORT OF AND THEN. WE
CAN. MAKE AN ASSESSMENT PROVIDED
THOSE ARE APPROVED IN. WHETHER
THAT DID IN FACT AFFECT THE
PARTICIPATION RATE BECAUSE WE'D
LIKE TO SEE THE HUNTER. YES
SENATOR JOB. YOU ANY. I DO- AND
THIS IS. FOR- I SEE. WHAT IS
CLEAR THAT THE YOU SEE IN THE C.
YEAR CAN YOU PER THE BY OF THE.
TWO FOR. I'M NOT SURE THAT.
QUESTIONS. BECAUSE HE SEEMS HE
HAS HONOR I DON'T HAVE THE DATA
READILY AVAILABLE BY THE. AS
REQUIRED ON THE BALANCE OF THEIR
DREAMLAND AND IN THEIR USUALLY-
ARE QUITE AND SO I COULD FOLLOW
WITH YOUR STAFF TO THAT
INFORMATION AFTER THE HEARING.
AND WE DO ALSO HAVE SOME THAT
YOU SEE ESTIMATED ON THE BALLOT
SNATCHING PER. I THINK THE I OF
THE TO TWENTY. ONE I'M AND IT I
RECALL THE BALLOTS WERE QUITE
HIGHWAYS SEVERAL TIMES AND WILL
SPAN AND I HERE. MARCH AND-
THANK YOU TO THE PANEL. WE'RE
GONNA MOVE TO OUR LAST ITEM
WHICH IS ISSUE THIRTEEN WHICH IS
OVERSIGHT ON FOOD NAY- PIECES OF
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE BUDGET
ACT IN OUR ONE PANELIST IS CHECK
FROM HER FROM THE CALIFORNIA
STUDENT AID COMMISSION WELCOME
TO THE COMMITTEE. THANK YOU SURE
LAYERED AND I AM I AM PLEASED TO
JOIN YOU TODAY TO PROVIDE THESE
UPDATES ON- THREE PROGRAMS THAT
COLLECTIVELY REPRESENTED ONE
POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLARS THAT
THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET
AGREEMENT- OUTLINES AND WAS PART
OF REALLY WHAT WAS A HISTORIC
YEAR IN THE STATE'S INVESTMENT
AND FINANCIAL AID IN PROMOTING
COLLEGE AFFORDABILITY. YOU HEARD
FROM ME EARLIER THIS MONTH ABOUT
OUR IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
CALTRAIN EXPANSION AND WHERE WE
ARE IN DISCUSSIONS AROUND THE
REVISED MIDDLE CLASS SCHOLARSHIP
PROGRAM. THESE THREE PROGRAMS
REFLECT MORE TARGETED EFFORTS
THAT SERVE A SPECIFIC
POPULATIONS IN ADDITION TO YOUR
OUTSIDE OF THE CAL GRANT
PROGRAMS WILL CLASS SCHOLARSHIP.
SO ALL START WITH A FEW UPDATES
ON THE LEARNING ALIGNED
IMPLEMENT PROGRAM WHICH- AS YOUR
AGENDA MATERIALS REFLECT- HAD AN
APPROPRIATION OF TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS AND THE TWENTY
ONE BUDGET AND A PROPOSED
INVESTMENT OF ANOTHER THREE
HUNDRED MILLION IN ONE TIME
FUNDING. AND THIS YEAR'S
PROPOSED BUDGET FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION AND I'M FOR THE
PURPOSES OF PROVIDING OUR PUBLIC
COLLEGE AND UNIVERSITY CAMPUSES
WITH FUNDS TO CREATE LEARNING A
LINE DEPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES AS
THE NAME WOULD SUGGEST. THAT
WOULD PROVIDE UNDER REPRESENTED
STUDENTS WITH AN OPPORTUNITY TO
GAIN EXPERIENCE IN THEIR FIELD
OF STUDY OR- THERE ARE FIELD OF%
CAREER INTERESTS. THE ROLE FOR
THE STUDENT AID COMMISSION AND
THIS PROGRAM IS TO WORK WITH OUR
CAMPUS PARTNERS AND DEVELOP A
PROGRAM GUIDELINES. THIS YEAR AS
THE BUDGET AGREEMENT REFLECTED
LAST YEAR THIS YEAR WAS INTENDED
FOR- PLANNING AND DEVELOPMENT OF
GUIDELINES SO THAT IN THE NEXT
ACADEMIC YEAR TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE ACADEMIC YEAR STUDENTS CAN
START TO ACTUALLY ACCESS THESE
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES. MR
NATE COMMISSION HAS FORMED A
WORKGROUP WITH OUR CAMPUS AND
STATEMENT PARTNERS HELP ADVISE
US ON WHAT THIS PROGRAM
GUIDELINES SHOULD LOOK LIKE AND
WORK THROUGH A QUESTIONS THAT
WE'RE ALREADY HEARING ABOUT FROM
THOSE CAMPUS PARTNERS AND
ANTICIPATE HEARING MORE ABOUT AS
THIS ROLLS OUT. THIS GROUP IS
CURRENTLY MEETING WEEKLY- AND
WERE- LOOKING TOWARDS THE END
ISSUE ALL RELEASED OF THE
PROGRAM- IN THE NEXT- MONTH OR
SO. IT WOULD THAT AND- I'LL INTO
. TO DRUM IF THEY WERE LIKE TO
PER. SIGN ON TO THAT AGREE.
BEFORE THE END THIS YEAR. SO
THAT THE STUDENTS COMMISSION
COULD AWARD- CHIU FOR TWO.
CAMPUS THERE SURE FUNDS BASED ON
NUMBER OF HEALTH TO. THAT ARE
SERVED BY THAT CAN. I WOULD JUST
NOTE THAT IF PROBABLY THIS IS
THE- HURDLE OR THE MOST. FOR A
WITH THIS. IS THE- FOR. OUR
CAMPUS PARTNERS WHO WE ARE
TASKED CREE DOES AND ALL.
ENTERING INTO AGREEMENTS WITH-
EITHER ON CAMPUS OR OFF CAMPUS
EMPLOYERS AND THAT AND THE
SUCCESS OF THIS PROGRAM WE
BELIEVE WILL REALLY BE
CONTINGENT ON HOW THOSE CAMPUS
ENTITIES ARE FINANCIAL AID
OFFICES CAN WORK COLLABORATIVELY
WITH OUR CAMPUS CAREER CENTERS
ON HOW THE STUDENT AID
COMMISSION. IN SUPPORT ALL THAT
WORK WE'RE ALSO MINDFUL THAT
THERE IS A NEED TO BE PROACTIVE
IN CONTACTING EMPLOYER PARTNERS
SO THIS DO YOU NEED COMMISSION
IS WORKING TO FIND MEANS TO
WHICH WE CAN HELP FACILITATE.
CAMPUS AN. EMPLOYER CONNECTIONS
FROM OUR SIDE AS WELL. ALL NOW
TRANSITION TO THE NEXT PROGRAM
HERE WHICH IS THE GOLDEN STATE-
TEACHER GRANT PROGRAM- THIS IS A
MISTER BERMAN OR AYE- FOR BE IT
FROM ME TO INTERRUPT BUT- WE ARE
TRYING TO END THIS HEARING BY
ELEVEN THIRTY. OR SO AND WE
START TO TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT SO
IF THERE IS ANY. BREVITY IN
THESE TWO ITEMS ARE PERSIUS. I
WILL KEEP IT CONCISE- CHAIR. SO-
WITH THE GOLD DAY TEACHER GRANT
PROGRAM FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IN ONE TIME FUNDING TO
EXPAND THE PROGRAM WE WERE
ALREADY IMPLEMENTING. PRIOR TO
THE TWENTY ONE BUDGET AGREEMENT.
AND THIS WAS A MORE
STRAIGHTFORWARD PROGRAM FIRST
INITIATED BECAUSE IT WAS AN
EXPANSION OF AN EXISTING PROGRAM
TO HELP STUDENTS ENTERING.
TEACHER PREPARATION PROGRAMS I
MEAN WHO COMMIT TO SERVING AT A
HIGH. PRIORITY SCHOOL WITH A
LARGE NUMBER OF ON YOU PEOPLE
CREATED A STUDENTS WHO COMMITTED
TEACHING IN HIGH HERTY FIELD.
THIS PROVIDES THEM WITH THE
GRANT OF UP TO TWENTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS TOWARD THE COST FOR THAT
TEACHER PREPARATION PROGRAM. WE
ARE ALREADY PROCESSING
APPLICATIONS AND AWARDING FUNDS
TO STUDENTS SO FAR WE'VE
RECEIVED OVER TWENTY EIGHT
HUNDRED. APPLICATIONS FROM
STUDENTS AND JUST THIS YEAR- AND
WE HAVE DATA THAT WE CAN SHARE
ON THE NUMBER OF DOLLARS THAT
HAVE BEEN AWARDED AS FAR. AND
HOW THOSE APPLICATIONS BREAK OUT
BY THE TYPE OF PROGRAM IN WHICH
THE STUDENTS ENROLLED IN THE
SUBJECT AREA. THAT THEY WORK ON
TO PURSUE. INSTRUCTION AND THEN
I'LL JUST- OUT FOR THE SAKE OF
BREVITY YOUR THE OTHER. THIRD
PROGRAM. I HAVE A MILLION
APPROPRIATION FROM LAST YEAR'S
BUT- I'M TOWARD THE GOAL STATE
AND TRAINING FOR PROGRAM. THIS
IS THE PROBE THAT PER. IN WHAT
LAW WORK A RESULT OF THE CODE
NINETEEN. CAN DAMAGE WITH UP TO
TWENTY HUNDRED GRANT TO OUR- AND
EDUCATION PROGRAM AT ONE OF OUR
PUBLIC INSTITUTIONS OR- CHIU AND
ENTER INTO A TRAINING PROGRAM.
FROM A PROVIDER ON THE ELIGIBLE
TRAINING PROVIDERS LIST THAT
NEEDS DEFINED CRITERIA- IN THE
STATUTE THAT WAS ESTABLISHED
AROUND THIS PROGRAM- WE'VE BEEN
CONSULTING WITH NOT ONLY OUR
USUAL SUSPECTS IN HIGHER
EDUCATION AROUND THIS PROGRAM
BUT ALSO WITH. WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT LEADERS GIVEN THE
TRAINING COMPONENT OF THIS
PROGRAM AND WE'VE ALSO SOLICITED
EXPERTISE FROM OUTSIDE OF THE
STATE. FROM OTHER ENTITIES THAT
HAVE IMPLEMENTED SIMILAR.
PROGRAMS WHAT WE'VE HEARD VERY
CLEARLY FROM ALL OF THOSE
PARTNERS IS REALLY THE NEED TO
BE MINDFUL ABOUT. HOW WE ROLL
THIS OUT AND HOW WE CAN PHASE
AND THIS TYPE OF PROGRAM KNOWING
THAT THE VOLUME OF APPLICATIONS
RECEIVED FOR OTHER PROGRAMS OF
THIS KIND HAS. REALLY
OVERWHELMED CAPACITY AT TIMES.
I'M SO WHAT WE'RE- DOING WITH
THIS PROGRAM IS REALLY AN
INTENTIONAL ROLLOUT TO A PILOT.
PROGRAM WE ARE FORCED BURNING.
STUDENT PARENTS WHO ARE ENROLLED
ONE OUR PUBLIC. ARE GONNA-
ABSENT OR NEVER. EDUCATION SINCE
THEY LOST WORK DUE TO GOOD NOW.
I'M AND RW THE MOST. STUDENTS
THAT WE CAN TARGET AND BACKED
APPLY. AND SUPPLE AND- OF THEIR
FINE. AID APPLICATION DATA. WILL
THEN SHIFT TO START TO SERVICE
PARENTS WERE IN OTHER FINANCED-
PROGRAMS THAT OUR PUBLIC
INSTITUTIONS THAT MAY NOT
QUALIFY FOR FINANCIAL AID. AND
THEN EVENTUALLY IN THE LAST STEP
OF THE PILOT PERIOD START TO
SERVE- INDIVIDUALS WE'RE
ENTERING PROGRAMS- TO THE HIGH
ROAD TRAINING PARTNERSHIP
PROGRAM. OF BEDS- IMPLEMENTED BY
THE CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD AS WELL AS
OTHER APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS
BEFORE WE FINALLY DO THE FULL
ROLLOUT TO ALL INDIVIDUALS. WHO
QUALIFY FOR THIS PROGRAM AND MAY
BE SEEKING TO ENTER A TRAINER
PARTNERSHIP. A TRAINING OR
EDUCATION PROGRAM- AND ALL
FINALLY OLDEST NOTED WE EXPECT
THIS FIRST WAVE. OF INVITATIONS
FOR A LIKELY ELIGIBLE STUDENTS
TO APPLY WITHIN THE NEXT FEW
WEEKS WE'RE JUST FINALIZING
THOSE MATERIALS AND I'VE BEEN
SHARING WITH OUR CAMPUS PARTNERS
WHAT THEY SHOULD LOOK OUT FOR
AND EXPECT. AS WE START TO YOU.
FOR STUDENTS ABOUT THIS
OPPORTUNITY. THANK YOU FOR MUCH
IN AND LET ME SAY THE- WE DID
HAVE A SEPARATE STUDENT AID THE
COMMISSION HEARING. SOME OF
THESE TO THE SIDE CAME UP IN
THAT. AND I DON'T WANT TO
DISCOUNT THE FACT THAT WE'RE
SHORT ON TIME FOR THE FACT THAT.
THESE WERE SIGNIFICANT PROGRAMS
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNTS OF MONEY AND
THAT WE HAVE SIGNIFICANT
INTEREST IN HOW THEY'RE BEING
IMPLEMENTED AND MAKING SURE.
THAT THE MONEY THAT WAS
APPROPRIATED GOES TO THE PURPOSE
OF ONCE SO LET ME JUST SAY I
APPRECIATE YOUR- OUR COMMENTS
AND WE JUST LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUED- INFORMATION. ON THE
SUCCESS OF THESE AND I DID NOTE
ONE. THAT YOU'RE HAVING TROUBLE
ED AND MAKING IT A PILOT BECAUSE
OF THE CHANCE TO IMPLEMENT IT SO
WE'LL JUST CONTINUE TO WANT TO
HEAR THOSE AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOU BEING WITH US
TODAY- WHAT WE HAVE A VERY
LIMITED AMOUNT OF TIME BUT-
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO THE
PUBLIC COMMENTS SECTION. AND LET
ME ASK A QUESTION WE HAVE A
NUMBER F PEOPLE IN THE ROOM.
ARE YOU INTERESTED IN MAKING
PUBLIC COMMENTS. YEAH OKAY THEN
THEN THIS IS WHAT WE'RE GOING TO
DO TODAY BECAUSE WE SAW A PHONE
COMMONSENSE AND WE ONLY HAVE
ABOUT TWELVE MINUTES TO DO THIS
I WOULD APPRECIATE. YOU SAYING
YOUR NAME. YOUR AFFILIATION AND
JUST WHAT YOUR FOR. A JUST A
SENTENCE OR TWO ON WHAT YOU'RE
FOR SO WE CAN HEAR FROM YOU ALL
BUT THAT WOULD. A KEVIN MCCARTY
ON BEHALF OF UNDERGROUND
SCHOLARS INITIATIVE. THE UC
SYSTEM'S A STUDENT GROUP WHO
HAVE BEEN IMPACTED BY.
INCARCERATION WE WERE NOT AND
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AND WE ARE
ASKING FOR FOUR MILLION DOLLARS
IN THE MAY REVISED. OKAY THANK
YOU FIND REJECT THAT AND IF
EVERYONE ELSE'S- IS FROM A OF
THAT POINT OF VIEW IT WOULD BE
GREAT TO JUST SAY YOUR NAME YOUR
AFFILIATION AND WE AGREE. SO ARE
WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE. HELLO
MY NAME'S KRISTEN FEES I'M HERE
ALSO REPRESENTING UNDERGROUND
SCHOLARS FOR UC BERKELEY AND I
AGREE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. HI
MY NAME IS ANDREA. HI MY NAME IS
UNDER A COMPOST I AM A PERFECT
PROSPECT THE STUDENT- THROUGH
THE UC'S ARE FROM FOR BOTH
COLLEGE AND I AGREE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. HI MY NAME IS HI MY
NAME IS LOUIS XIMENES I'M A
FORMER INCARCERATED- STUDENT
ALSO SAID IN A UCLA ON BEHALF OF
UNDERGROUND COLLEGE STUDENT
INITIATIVE. AND I WOULD YOU TO
SUPPORT THE FONG GOING FOR
MILLION A DOLLAR BUDGET FOR
UNDER GOD CALLS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- HI MY NAME IS
ERIC GENTRY. I'M THE PROGRAM
MANAGER FOR SHOULD BOW COLLEGES
RISING SCHOLARS NETWORK AND AS A
FOR A FOR MANY CARS OR THE
INDIVIDUAL. I HAVE A FIRSTHAND
KNOWLEDGE OF HOW IMPORTANT THIS
CONTINUED BY THE AND AS A
FUNDING IS AND I AGREE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. HELLO MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME'S RECYCLING ON
AND I'M ON BEHALF OF THE
UNDERGROUND SCHOLARS PROGRAM AS
WELL AS THE RISE PROGRAM. AND I
APPROVED THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS RUDOLPH HOWELL- WORK
WITH THE RUBICON WHICH IS A
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION FOR PHONE
ACROSS REYES STUDENTS HELPING
GET THE SCHOOL AND I SUPPORT
THIS- THIS MEASURE. THANK YOU.
MORNING MY NAME IS MORE REWARDS
I'M A CURRENTLY AT THIS
ADMINISTRATION'S FIELD NEXT FALL
COLLEGE REPORTER RIGHT PROGRAM.
AND I UNDERSTAND I AND I KNOW
HOW IMPORTANT TO SUPPORT THIS.
ONE IS FOR SUPPORTING THE
SUPPORT STILL INSTEAD OF A
GOLDEN SHE- AND I AGREE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. HI MY NAME
MICHELLE MAXWELL I'M WITH THE ON
THE GROUND. UNIVERSE CAL
BERKELEY. AND I AGREE THANK YOU
. HELLO MY TO GO ORTEGA I AM THE
RISE PROGRAM I'M- AS A COUNTRY
EXTINGUISHER. NOT AGREE WITH THE
MONEY WITH. THANK YOU MUCH. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME'S WILLIAM B.
S. FOREMAN KERR STREET IT WOULD
IN A UC BERKELEY AND I AGREE
WITH THE REQUEST OF FORMING
DOLLARS TO SUPPORT OUR COMMUNITY
CENTER PEOPLE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. HI MY NAME IS LILY ANGEL
I'M A FORMERLY INCARCERATED
MOTHER AND SOMEONE THAT'S BEEN
SYSTEM IMPACTED THEIR WHOLE LIFE
I SUPPORT THIS MEASURE. AND I
URGE YOU TO SUPPORT IT AS WELL-
COMING FROM UCLA. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. HI MY NAME IS JOHN I'M A
SENIOR UCLA PART OF UNDERGROUND
SCHOLARS- I'M ALSO INFORMALLY
CORSETTI STUDENT I WOULD LIKE TO
ASK YOU FOR YOUR CONTINUED
CONTINUES SUPPORT OF THE
UNDERGROUND SCHOLARS IN THE UC
SYSTEM. THANK YOU THANK YOU. I'M
ON MONTEVIDEO ASK IS ALSO KNOWN
AS FROGGY- ARMAGH IS OTHER GUY
EISENBERG HELD ON THE MOSCOW.
NOMOGRAM UCLA ALL WARNED ON THE
LOS SHOPPING SURVEY. AND I THINK
THIS WILL BE GROW THAT WE ARE
NOT ABLE TO. AND I WANT TO- I.
SUPPORT FOR FORMING IN THE AND-
OF. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN- MY NAME IS
JOSH WAS A LEASE I AM WITH THE
UNDERGROUND SCHOLARS PROGRAM ARE
YOU SEE SANTA CRUZ- I AM
FORMERLY INCARCERATED AFTER
ELEVEN YEARS OF INCARCERATION I
WENT THROUGH SALINAS COMMUNITY
COLLEGE GRADUATED FROM UC SANTA
CRUZ AND NOW I'M CURRENTLY IN
THE MASTER'S PROGRAM AT
SACRAMENTO STATE AND I WOULD
STRONGLY- ENCOURAGE- YOURSELF
AND THE REST THE COMMITTEE TO
SUPPORT THIS THANK YOU THANK YOU
AND LET ME TELL YOU THAT THIS
YOU CAN SIT IN THIS CHAIR WITH
THE UC SANTA CRUZ. DEGREE SO
GLAD YOU'RE HERE THANK YOU NEXT
WEEK HELLO MY NAME IS MIGUEL
BROWN I'M A PROBLEM EMERALD
UNDERGROUND SCHOLARS UCLA. AND
AMONG THE UNDERGRADUATE STUDENT
THERE AS WELL AND YOU KNOW
ALMOST AS YOU TO SUPPORT THIS
PROGRAM FOR FOUR MILLION DOLLARS
BUDGET PHONES OFF COLORS ALL
ACROSS THE YEARS HE'S VOTE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. HI MY
NAME'S FEATHER- UNDERGRADUATE AT
UC BERKELEY- REPRESENTING UC
BERKELEY UNDERGROUND SCHOLARS.
AND I'M HERE JUST TO- URGE YOU
TO SUPPORT THE FOREMAN IN BUDGET
FOR- ANYONE'S COLOR. THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS JAY ONE SAM ALMOST
SENIOR UNDERGRADUATE STUDENT AT
UC BERKELEY WITH A- YEAH
FORMALLY INCARCERATED AND- THIS
PROGRAM REALLY HELPS A LOT OF
PEOPLE AND REALLY HELPED ME BE
ABLE TO STAY IN SCHOOL AND
BILLION A DRIVE SO I WOULD ALSO
URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THIS. THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR SHARING YOUR
COMMENTS. HELLO CHAIRMAN.
ANYBODY ON A MONEY GO ROUND
MORRELL OVER CARS REYES. UC'S
BARBARA I AM THE AFRICA CORN. OF
THE PROBE. AND I WANT TO SAY ALL
WITH UNDERGROUND CARS AND- I NOT
BEEN A SAID THE TO THE UNIVERSE
OF BROKERS FOR A GRADUATE
PROGRAM. AND I BELIEVE THAT THAT
OCCASION FOR BILLION DOLLAR WITH
STRONG TO BE CHANGED PEOPLE'S
LIVES AS A STRONG AS A SOCIAL
AGENCIES TO PROVIDE THESE NEW
CHANGE. BUT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND I HOPE YOU SUPPORT THIS.
THANK. YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
YOUR COMMENTS. I AM OF ASK THIS
. I WOULD UNDER SCHOLAR JUST.
AND I'M I'M HERE- YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND LET ME JUST SAY ONE THING
BEFORE YOU GO WHY UP I THINK
THAT THAT EVERYBODY THAT'S
TESTIFYING INCLUDING THE TWO
THAT I HAVEN'T HEARD FROM YET
I'LL PROBABLY FIND IT HARD TO
STAND UP HERE AND SAY THEIR NAME
A. N. AND IT JUST INDICATE WHO
THEY ARE IN THIS AND I JUST
WANTED TO KNOWLEDGE THAT AND SAY
WE REALLY APPRECIATE THE FACT
THAT YOU'RE HERE TODAY AND WE
REALLY APPRECIATE THE FACT. THAT
YOU'RE STEPPING UP FOR WHAT YOU
BELIEVE IN AND IF YOU TO EXPRESS
THAT TO THE OTHER PEOPLE MORE
WAY I'D REALLY APPRECIATE IT
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE AND OUR
LAST TWO COMMERCE REGULATOR-
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JOHN
LAMM- UNDERGRADUATE AT UC
BERKELEY I'M FORMERLY
INCARCERATED AFTER SERVING
SIXTEEN YEARS IN PRISON I AM A
BENEFICIARY OF THE UNDERGROUND
SCHOLARS PROGRAM WITHOUT THEM I
WOULD NOT BE A UC BERKELEY RIGHT
NOW. AND I'M STRONGLY URGE YOU
TO SUPPORT THE FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS FOR PROGRAM SO WE CAN
HELP MORE SYSTEM IMPACTED PEOPLE
TO ACHIEVE HIGHER EDUCATION
THANK. YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. HELLO MISTER CHAIRMAN
ANOTHER ROUND OF AND REPRESENT
THE U. BROWN ON THE- CALL
ALTHOUGH. PHONE AND TWENTY SIX.
AND NOW MY- OF THE ON THE GROUND
OM'S FATHER PROGRAM. NOW- JULIE
OF SUPPORT- THE FOR- GIVEN US
FREE. AT THE UC. JUST IT CLOSE
THE GAP. THE THAT ALL OF BE SURE
TO HAVE BEEN A- TO THE- CODE
COMMITTEE CONNOR. AND THE CAR
SYSTEM WE ARE THE BEST YOU. TO
FOR ME AND- ACROSS RIGHT
STUDENTS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. AND LET ME JUST NOTE
THAT. I CAN SEE THAT THEY'RE
STILL. OF FIND PEOPLE THAT WERE
LISTENING AND- I HOPE VERY A TO
INTO. ALL THE TESTIMONY. AND
WHAT IT MEANT HERE IN THE
PROGRAM SO WHAT THANK EVERYBODY
IN THE ROOM. OF THAT TESTIFIED.
AND IF YOU. ONE SEVENTY. SEVEN
IN THE QUEUE THEY- ARE EIGHT WE
HAVE SO ARE WE GOING TO COME OFF
TEST BUT WE HAVE SO P. IN THE
QUEUE ON THE PHONE MODERATOR
WELCOME LET'S JUST TO NAME
AFFILIATION AND WHAT IS SUPPORT
AND WILL TAKE THE SEVEN THAT ARE
IN THE QUEUE MODERATOR WELCOME
TO THE COMMITTEE. THANKS FOR
STANDING BY. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND LINE NUMBER TWENTY SIX
THE VERY FIRST COMMENT IN Q.
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. NINE TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI J.
LEADING COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS GREEN AND LOOKED ONLINE
MEMBERS CUT. AND I WANTED TO
REQUESTED KINDLY THE BOARD
DECLARED A MILLION DOLLAR FOR
PLUS IT ON GOING BUT IT BUT
YOU'VE BEEN IT OR NOT. STEP IN
OUR GAP AND IT'S THE-
HISTORICALLY UNDER. OF MY- AND
DOLLARS CAN THANK SO MUCH AND WE
APPRECIATE IT AND MORNING NO WE
APPRECIATE TO YOU A THE WORK YOU
DO IT KALP. MODERATE SECOND THE
CALL. MY NAME. YOUR LINE IS A
PLEASE AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
STEPHANIE GOLDMAN ON THE HOW THE
FACT ISSUES OF THE COMMUNITY
WERE GRATEFUL FOR LAST YEAR WILL
TEMPT FUN IN THE SUB LET.
CONTINUE TO OVERSEE AND WE ARE
SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR EQUAL I
OPPORTUNITY BY PROPOSAL THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH A
MODERATOR NEXT CALLER. MIND A
YOUR IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THE TERM WHERE'D MY NAME IS
SEVEN OLD I BECAUSE OF A URUGUAY
AFFAIRS BUT A COPY TO. AND I OF
ALL AS COMPANY OFFICE MICHAEL
PEOPLE CAN I'M HERE TO MAKING
BUT IT'S MILLION DOLLARS A I'M
GOING FOR FOSTER YOUTH AND
STUDENTS ACROSS A FEW YOU.
DIDN'T HAVE BEEN DIFFICULT
AFFECTED BY NINETY NO MORE
LIKELY TO STRUGGLE BASICALLY AND
FIGURE IN X. THE TERM IMPACT OF
TRAUMA. BUDGET ALLOCATION OF
COMMERCE OR I WAS JUST FROM I
WOULD HAPPEN NEED IT ME JEFF I
WAS JUST TRYING TO DO NOW. A FEW
AND- THANK YOU FOR YOUR COM MORE
NECK CALL. UNDER YOUR BILL TO
CONTACT THE THINK APPLE BOX YOU
. THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. MONTEREY NEXT CALL.
NINE TWENTY NINE. YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JOHN JAMES
CURRENT DIRECTOR OF THE PROGRAM
IS COLLEGE PROGRAM AT CAL STATE
UNIVERSITY DOMINGUEZ HILLS AND
WE ARE IN FULL SUPPORT OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL FOR TWELVE
MILLION AND ONGOING FUNDING FOR
FOURTEEN SUPPORT PROGRAM TO SEE
ISSUE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
THANK YOU. SHARE COMMENTS
MODERATOR NEXT CALL. NINE TWENTY
FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
MEDINA AND I'M READY AND I'M THE
PROGRAM COORDINATOR FOR OUR PAST
YOUTH PROGRAM CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY CHICO AND I AM IN
FULL SUPPORT OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL FOR TWELVE MILLION
DOLLARS IN ONGOING FUNDING. FOR
SUPPORT OF A FOSTER YOUTH
PROGRAM THAT YES THANK YOU SO
MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
MODERATOR THE SHOULD BE THE
SEVENTH AND FINAL CALL. WE DO
HAVE A FEW MORE THAT JOINED I'M
SORRY WE ARE NEED TO BE OUT OF
HERE WE AGREED TO TAKE SEVEN TO
SIX TO SEVEN THIS WILL BE THE
FINAL CALL. FIFTY NINE TWELVE.
YOUR LAST COME INTO Q. YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. CREATED
HELLO MY NAME IS JORDAN ALUMNI
CAL THINK FULLER CAN GUARDIAN
COLLEGE PROGRAM AND LEGISLATIVE
MANAGER OF CALIFORNIA YOUTH
CONNECTION ELECTED SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL UP TWELVE
MILLION DOLLARS AND ON GOING
FUNDING FOR FOSTER YOUTH SUPPORT
PROGRAMS AT THE ISSUE. THANK YOU
. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND LET ME
APOLOGIZE TO EVERYONE FOR THE
FACT THAT. THERE WAS BREVITY IN
THESE COMMENTS AND- FOR ANYONE
THAT MADE A COMMENT THAT WAS
ABBREVIATED OR WAS UNABLE TO
SPEAK. ARE YOU CAN SUBMIT YOUR
COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE BUDGET AND FISCAL
REVIEW SUBCOMMITTEE ONE OR VISIT
OUR WEBSITE OF. YOUR COMMENTS
AND SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HEAR
THEM. ARE IN RESPONSE TO THIS
AND INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY IN
THE OFFICIAL HEARING RECORD SO
ONCE AGAIN WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PATIENCE WITH THE OF THE TIMING
OF THIS. THANKS EVERYONE FOR
THEIR PATIENCE AND COOPERATION
WE'VE CONCLUDED THE AGENDA FOR
TODAY'S HEARING THE SENATE
BUDGET AND FISCAL REVIEW
SUBCOMMITTEE ONE STANDS
ADJOURNED.